so they dropped the charges against Alec
Baldwin and uh I guess we should have
seen that coming he's not going to face
any accountability for what he did so
we'll uh we'll talk about that and we
got some other really big news tonight
BuzzFeed news no longer exists so you
know everybody's celebrating that and uh
I tweeted about it and all of these
journalists are really mad that I
tweeted about it so uh that's too bad
for them and then uh at the same time
they're also whinging because Elon Musk
took away all their blue check marks and
now they're complaining and a bunch of
these prominent journalists are like we
stand in solidarity with PBS so we're
quitting Twitter and it's like well
there's the door don't let it hit you on
the hitch on the ass on your way out and
uh well it's fun to watch them whinge so
we'll talk about that and a bunch of
other stories the one story I think we
we I I think we'll have to get into this
is interesting is uh some drama where uh
comedian Dave Landau made some uh
accusations against Stephen Crowder
which is now hitting the the media press
and I think there are some things we
should follow up on considering this the
uh there's a bunch of stuff related to
the contract I don't want to say too
much just yet because there's a lot of
intricate details but there was there's
a bunch of stuff in there and I think
what was it in uh Dave and uh
quarterback Garrett are joining the
blaze that's right yeah interesting so
so Crowder leaves and then they stay so
we'll talk about that my friends before
we get started why don't you pop over to
castbrew.com and purchase some cast brew
coffee this is our coffee brand that's
right you can purchase your rise with
Roberto Jr that is Roberto Jr our
rooster his signature breakfast blend a
light roast or Appalachian nights a very
robust dark blend both in ground or
whole bean then we got Colombian we got
French roast pick up your cast brew
coffee because we're sponsoring
ourselves we're not going to sit back
and wait for someone to make a company
that we think has good values we're
gonna make a company that we know has
good values we're not going to wait
around for some company to cancel us
because someone made up some fake
garbage on the internet we're going to
make our own company and sponsor
ourselves and this is our coffee brand
that we will be selling at our coffee
shop which is currently under
construction and being put together we
own the building we got it in West
Virginia now we've got to do all the
work to make that coffee shop second and
third floor Social Clubs it's gonna be a
lot of fun also
head over to timcast.com click join us
become a member because we have a
members only uncensored show it's going
to be a lot of fun it'll be tonight at
10 10 p.m Eastern Time
if you sign up for at least six months
or sign up at the 25 level you can
submit questions and potentially be one
of our nightly callers and actually ask
us and our guests some questions and
join the show and it's the most fun part
of the night so smash that like button
subscribe to this Channel and the reason
the uncensored portion of the show is
gonna be a lot of fun is because joining
us tonight we got Ryan long and Danny
polish Chuck in Kanye's chair here it is
Kanye's sure yeah Danny actually said
before we started he was like I want to
pick up where Kanye left talk and I said
I don't know about this it was bad for
the brand we had to I had to I had to
ask him you know we don't normally do
this Danny but you know we're gonna ask
you not to pick up sure sure if you
could please yeah so uh
introduce yourselves
Danny quote tweeted Kanye and he said
you're the goat I'm cleaning up the
cleaning up tonight
okay so you're a comedian sure the boys
cast in the building yeah what's the
best joke you ever told no no
[Laughter]
you can do one of your skins for us
well the one time he got thrown out of a
club uh yeah so you guys you guys have
the voice cast you make comedy videos on
the internet yeah the boys cast podcast
for exclusively the boys if you're a
lady keeps keep scrolling sister you can
you're gonna have to deal with BuzzFeed
not news
listicles yeah uh that is I have a
couple listicles uh 10 reasons that I'm
gay so this is
it's a lot of reasons
Ryan's coming in it's hot this is oh
yeah we're not talking about BuzzFeed
yet okay so that's Ryan long uh and then
Danny you're the same thing yeah yeah
I'm the same thing uh less listicles
though I don't know 10 reasons I'm by 10
reasons I'm not ready because I'm an
ally
for all the people yes uh comedian
co-host I always cast I have a feeling
I'm just going to sit back and let you
guys be funny the whole time yeah take
an easy night I am so jacked up on
whatever this caffeine you gave me all
right we got we are jacked up and we've
got energy drinks here your caffeine and
then your whole staff has coffee pouches
yep yeah they all do every single one of
them which is sort of Game Changer I was
loving it yeah they walk like five times
faster because of it I found that by
spending the ten dollars per week on the
little pouches increases work
productivity by 400 like the Steve Jobs
School management right here and they
love it with stimulants I mean that's
actually why they do coffee you know
that right like why offices have coffee
because they want their employees jacked
up on caffeine sure yeah yeah the Nazis
did that too okay
like 15 seconds ago but I was like
should I say that on YouTube I should I
love that you were in your head 15
seconds worth of like do I say this do I
not spend a little you get along do I
not yep I'm tired I'm in Ian's here and
they're coffee nuts
hi everyone good to see you oh and you
know Stephen King didn't lose his blue
check mark on Twitter although he's not
Twitter so I don't know what the hell's
going on oh this is you said this is the
funny part of the story that Elon
apparently paid for other people's check
marks so that these celebrities still
have blue checks and everyone's like why
do these celebrities still have the
check marks they're they're paying for
Twitter uh they're like no no we're not
we're not only gonna but we'll talk
about devious we got uh surgery we're
jumping on the guns right yep yeah yeah
yeah yeah that was a Segway the gun
Serge du preo what's up guys uh I'm
excited for this let's go let's jump
into that first story ladies and
gentlemen
we lost them
we did not get him we lost him Alec
Baldwin has charges dropped in fatal
onset rust shooting and I I cannot I
can't believe it I mean I can believe it
but like I am trying to express my shock
at that they're gonna it's this Brazen
so apparently they're saying that they
dismissed the charges because new
evidence emerged showing that the gun
could have fired on its own
and uh I just I gotta say you know let's
just let's just read it here they say
charges against Alex Baldwin have been
dropped sources familiar with the matter
said Baldwin 65 have been charged with
two counts of involuntary manslaughter
quote we are pleased the decision to
dismiss the case against Alec Baldwin
blah blah blah says his lawyers well uh
Santa Fe district attorney declined to
comment his next court appearance in the
case had been set for May 3rd the film's
armor Hannah Gutierrez read was also
charged a gun enhancement charges were
filed in both Baldwin and Gutierrez read
were dropped uh gun enhancement charges
filed the case against both Baldwin and
Gutierrez were dropped late February so
I guess we could have seen this coming
her attorneys confirmed that she still
faces charges saying in a statement that
they fully expect at the end of this
process that Hannah will also be
exonerated so it's like I just think
it's kind of funny that Alec Baldwin
gets his charges dropped you know and
he's the one who shot the lady and then
the other lady the armorer still has the
charges and she didn't even hold the gun
pull the trigger she should have thought
of that before she had didn't have her
millionaire lawyers
that is her fault yeah yeah she should
have considered being a millionaire and
having better lawyers well I'm sure she
got the job I'm surprised that you're
surprised to be honest like to me this
was duh I'm like surprised that you
thought there was a chance that he was
going down like doing time well not so
much they would do time but like that
they would slap him on the wrist with
something and at least at least feign
that they actually hold people
accountable for shooting people in the
chest and killing them I think this was
the extent of it was just this whatever
these charges were right this was his
punishment to go hey this is scary huh I
I actually think he did it like my
opinion of the matter is that he
intentionally murdered this woman
premeditated murder he had he had the
bullets on him everyone's like where do
the bolts go do a documentary about this
like because there was a brand when
Brandon Lee that happened there's like
40 documentaries about it like all
everyone thinks that Yakuza was involved
essentially and he like oh that money
and then they you know whatever get
involved with the prop people they got
their inside guy and then his story
that's kind of what you see as but you
see Alec Baldwin didn't like the girl
well so there's a bunch of different is
there circumstantial evidence one is
that he gave an interview where he he
very much expressed disdain for this
woman saying that she was antagon
antagonistic to him that she was giving
him instruction she wasn't supposed to
be giving because she's not a director
she hates that coming out yeah it sounds
like his daughter right no but for sure
everyone knows he's a hot head and uh he
was talking about how it made him angry
and so then you had crew complaining
then you had wage issues safety issues
and then when she gets shot he claims
his finger wasn't on the trigger and
then a video comes out showing that his
finger actually was okay one thing I
will say is anyone on that set got shot
I bet you that there was evidence of
Alec Baldwin hating them and yelling at
them at their point legitimately they
could have been like the the seventh ads
from the cooking guy and then they go oh
yeah there's Alec ball here's a video of
Alec Baldwin yelling at him in the
Janitor's Closet
is there like a precedent there if they
say that he goes who knows who fired the
gun and like couldn't anybody use that
in the future be like I don't know
what does that mean you'll see what what
I had read I don't think I have it in
this ABC news story but that they said
that the gun could have fired without
him doing it so they're dropping the
charges but like why would they sell the
charges against the lady but I think the
important details The Last Detail to
come out was that they found live
ammunition in his in his gun belt yeah
so everyone's wondering like how did
this this real bullet get in this prop
gun and then it's like well Alec Baldwin
had the bullets so it's kind of like a
guy Robs a Bank wearing a mask that
looks like a clown and then you find
Alec Baldwin holding the mask and you're
like wonder where he got the mask from
like so he had the bullets before they
they they took his gun belt and found
bullets in his gun belt minus one but
that's a pro well I don't know about
minus one yeah
but like they were like I think there
were five live bullets found and two of
them were in his gun belt I think if he
had premeditated he would have had one
live bullet and no other evidence
because they're having all those other
bullets on them just seems like so
either this is nothing or first degree
murder this is like if he literally
brought it
and it could be that they didn't think
they could get him on murder charges
because they're very very hard to prove
so they were like we just let them does
this mean that um Helena Hutchins
husband wanted to drop the case or is
this like the federal government the
government is like we just can't can't
bring I mean I I worked on a movie where
I actually had to shoot somebody and I
can tell you they're like they're just
like here like I never checked I took
their the armorer's word for it that
this is not live ammunition you were
sort of a diva though they were like
picked up uh put it in my hand please
excuse me assistant I'm drooling so did
they they opened the gun and you looked
and they were like these are dummy
rounds and you're like okay oh no it was
um it was like uh you know I'm not a gun
guy but like you know no it wasn't like
a revolver but no this guy's hands he
goes this is a cold gun and he goes
right when we say action you point at
the guy you can check it out on 2B it's
called Phil City and then uh and just
like shot the guy I don't know and then
the scribs went off and all that stuff
but I took his word for it that there
was not live rounds like I don't inspect
the gun Danny kept winking at the guy
and the guy's like stop wink no it
actually is going loud and clear but
you're supposed to check the gun correct
I mean this one I mean this is an
independent Canadian film I don't know
how it works in America
look people who listen to the show no
guns for the most part it is insane in
my view that someone would hand you a
gun and say don't check it okay okay now
point it at that person and pull the
trigger I literally did that that's
insane think about
to murder somebody in that case like if
someone really wanted the Selena
Hutchins dead then if it really wasn't
Alec Baldwin did it they'd be like here
Alec here's a gun don't check it for
live ammo now pointed at her and pull
the trade I will say so we're like she
because she was the cinematographer I
believe right she probably had like hey
there's like 10 people there right like
the fact that he pointed at her like if
it was an ad you know if you're saying
someone wanted to kill her yeah well
they're saying it was supposed to be
like he was pointing at the camera or
something but the bullet went through
her chest and then into another guy okay
so if you want to like let's say break a
window in your movie like in America
it's like okay you need 14 more guys
that you have to handle like you know
what I mean hey this person's gonna be
on the horse okay now we need nine horse
guys
regulation for all this stuff is like
pretty wild so that's why it's not just
like oh some we just hire some gun
person off Craigslist it's like a whole
thing well I think that's what they were
doing actually because their budget now
their budget was really low really yeah
I just mean if it's like uh uh sag like
there's just crazy regulations around
that stuff the thing is
Donald Trump is they're trying to put
him in jail because he filed his
paperwork improperly
yeah Alec Baldwin killed a lady yeah
like he killed he brought a gun at her
and shot her and she died yeah really
and like Donald Trump is gonna go to
jail and probably paid some hush money
to some girls too yeah we have both yeah
I wonder how many and his wife is not
actually from Spain that's the one that
gets me
but I think that's why the real Smoking
Gun I think that that exemplifies
exactly I know Alec bald is not a silver
bullet guy he's more of a bud like
he probably is
but yeah that's the the the
um
I think the reason people care so much
about the Alec Baldwin thing is because
we're currently watching say you know
you've got the feds you've got New York
and Georgia going after Donald Trump all
for these weird nebulous charges like
you uh paid a lawyer and then when you
wrote down what the payment was for you
put Legal Services instead of paying a
hooker or something you're gonna go to
jail for that and a New York jury's
probably going to convict him meanwhile
Alec Baldwin pointed a gun at a woman
pulled the trigger and shot her and uh
she died it's such an example of if if
the world likes you you get to I guess
there's no political motive without it
no but we don't like Alex not like you
the greatest Trump impersonator
liberal sketch comedy show for five
years it was just held in jail with no
no charge it was in Romania of course
that's because they didn't like them if
they liked him they wouldn't have done
it he was taunting them though saying
the Romania is the most corrupt place
and he was like I love it here all right
we're going to show you how corrupt it
is you're right it is yeah we're gonna
arrest you but there's a bunch of uh uh
this is this is the perfect example of
if you hate Trump if you're in the
machine you're protected yeah there you
go
that's if but see in your mind there's a
zero percent chance that he didn't like
that this as actually he just someone
whatever happened wasn't him putting a
bullet in the gun like in your mind in
your mind 100 Alec Baldwin put that no
no no I think I just think because maybe
he is let me ask you a question if uh if
you walk in the room and Ian was uh
standing in front of a dead body with a
bullet in their chest and he was holding
a revolver and he had bullets in his
belt and he looks and he goes oh I
pointed at her and pulled the trigger
now she's dead would you be like must
have been an accident well if you can
also say that that guy was paid to give
me that gun and I'm being paid to hold
the gun and we have the whole thing on
camera yeah I think that at the very
least I'd still be like that sounds very
weird
sure I mean just think about how insane
it is you could be like you know if you
if you let's say your neighbor's
bothering you you'd be like hey you want
to do a job you want to do a movie you
want to do a movie you do a scene for my
YouTube video yeah
get the armor over here we're gonna have
it it's about a marine who's uh fighting
uh aliens aliens okay and so we're just
we need you to film a scene where he
aims a gun directly at you and then
fires it why is it my gun guy why is he
wearing a wife literally
it's like an episode of Law and Order
like that totally legit right where they
go like oh there will be a movie made
about this yeah I wonder how long two
years
himself because I really need the money
I know Billy Baldwin takes the role or
Daniel like one of the really crappy
ones like Daniel Baldwin playing at like
the ultimate how many Baldwins are there
there's a lot yeah but they're not all
related who's the one that's not related
Adam Adam Baldwin is that what it is
yeah I think so I really I think he's
the cool one that we like Stolen Valor
did we have him on the show before not
yet and then there's a guy from
Backdraft is that Billy Baldwin yeah
that's he's uh he's a real one yeah
you're saying that he's a real one yeah
True Blood True Blood all the way well
no I mean there's a True Blood you know
I was like using that show Let's uh
let's move on to this story this one um
should make everybody really happy and
give you guys a lot of material to make
jokes BuzzFeed news announces shutdown
some staff members will be offered jobs
at Huffington Post which CEO Jonah
Peretti said is less dependent on social
platforms uh and then I guess our news
team decided a picture of BuzzFeed on
fire was the appropriate one solid
thumbnails
I'm kind of thinking like that was your
last imagine that was your last
assignment
that is we have you till the end of the
day if you don't mind yeah I'm actually
impressed with our news team for
deciding that's the picture to use what
is that photo even of it's like from a
90s movie and there's like an office
like that draft maybe yeah speaking of
it's like and as BuzzFeed is being
burned off the wall is that AI develop
that thumbnail uh partially so it's like
putting together a bunch of different uh
that's what happened well basically even
was it like a month ago that they were
kind of like Hey we're gonna have ai
replacing most of our Riders at BuzzFeed
and the stock kind of jumped because
people were pretty pumped about it did
it yeah
it's back down below companies are doing
Mass layoffs if you guys have been
following there's like uh Patrick was
talking like the bottom 10 of all these
corporations are getting cut but they're
keeping wage they're keeping prices and
sales the same so their stocks going up
companies stocks are rising right now
stockholders are very happy that's part
of when you do you know low-level
layoffs I don't know what comes they did
like 40 reverse mergers too do you see
the company I think it was Irma is or
something and it was uh it was like some
super luxury brand and their CEO this
woman was like got a four million dollar
bonus and they didn't give any bonuses
this year yeah she was giving them this
like speech about like suck it up okay
sometimes you know you don't get your
bonus or whatever and she's doing the
zoom call and she's like I'm just sick
of people and all you're crying and all
this stuff she got killed the uh the
well journalism got really mad because
I've been just gloating and making fun
of it I even dancing on the grave a
little bit dancing or urinating I mean
more of a Calvin and Hobbes guy like I'm
you know like making fun of them so it's
a bit more um what's what's the rhyme
looking for it's more of a desecration
of this the spirit of BuzzFeed I mean
these I called I called I called them
racist which is like in their in their
world that's like whoa gloves are off
you know it's all dangerous that's their
n-word
they own complex yeah no let me tell you
BuzzFeed News ran a story where they
claimed a black man was killed fighting
over a fried chicken sandwich
did you guys ever hear that story no
I've seen that story no so uh when the
Popeyes chicken sandwich thing was going
on and the media was claiming that
everybody was fighting for sandwiches
BuzzFeed News ran a fake story claiming
that two guys fought to the death over a
fried chicken sandwich and when I
reached out to BuzzFeed news and said
guys the story is not real like check
your sources they basically told me to
go screw myself they were going to keep
keep the story up you ever want to work
in this industry well they're probably
like you know well this is performing
this thing yup that's exactly what it is
it look BuzzFeed runs headline of black
man murdered fighting over Fried Chicken
Sandwich they're getting tons of hits
and they don't care who they're getting
it from A View From a white supremacist
and A View From A leftist is to say it's
a number for an Advertiser boom yeah so
when I told the editor-in-chief like
this is not true his attitude was kind
of like so what this is true that they
want a Pulitzer Prize oh probably a
bunch of them those prizes are handing
out like Cracker jackets
no
he was doodling on a napkin and the guy
just came back
is that original
oh my God that's the best 10 best 10
list I've ever seen yeah that's the
majority of what they do they were like
popular for is the the you know 10
things that you know 10 years yeah but
that's BuzzFeed I know buzzfeed's still
cooking and they're and a lot of the
news people are gonna start to funnel
into like Huffington Post and some of
these other places
they're gonna get I warned that they'll
get increasingly more unhinged so I said
this back in 2018 BuzzFeed or BuzzFeed
news all of them yeah just because they
don't have their secret sauce of trump
well well that's true too but because
they're view because their viewership is
dependent upon escalation as time goes
on they have to keep being crazier and
crazier to keep someone's attention
right like if a dude goes outside your
house and he dresses like Hillary
Clinton with clown makeup on yeah and
juggles a bunch of bowling pins you're
gonna look out your window and you're
gonna be like guys everybody come look
at this thing what's going on wait do
you live near me in Brooklyn but the
next day because that guy lives right
outside right and you're not watching
him right now that's right the next day
you go oh the guy's out there again you
don't care so he's got to add a chicken
to the mix you're like hey the Hillary
Clinton guy he's got a chicken in there
now so they have to keep adding new
weird especially because they're not a
destination like if you you know if you
run a show and you have your core
viewers sometimes it might be up
sometimes you go through like phases
yeah no one's like they don't have a
core group of people I don't think that
like oh let me check out BuzzFeed news
every morning oh yeah just
it can't be a high number of people that
like every morning out on the porch I
gotta check out my BuzzFeed you know but
they actually said this that they're
it's all about just the social media
algorithms that's their whole thing so
buzzfeed's whole BuzzFeed news was all
about producing shock content on social
media to capture people who don't
actually care about the brand
yeah of course yeah yeah well that that
that's not gonna work and so I didn't
know that they were going to go they
were going to implode I mean BuzzFeed
stock is at like 70 cents or something
70 cents yeah from 10 bucks could you
imagine being stupid enough to have have
bought stock buzzfeeding whoa yeah
actually who was our buddy Matt who was
actually trying to pump that for a while
he goes he's like I have a feeling
shout out to Matt I hope you're not
watching
he's in journalism I mean he saw the
whole restruction he goes I think this
is like you want to bet on this Pony
right here
you want to bet on them to break their
leg so you buy put options and you would
have made yourself a fortune yeah yeah
no I mean there's especially in the last
two years like there's zero chance that
there ever like that they had their
Moment Like Trump covet all the mix
right sure yeah their stocks started to
drop in December of 2021. it's not just
them it is like in some ways the whole
industry the shock it is industry
they're not they're fake journalists
they're fake Clues if you will political
clickbait and like clicking uh chasing
ad Revenue instead of subscriber well
their ad Revenue thing is even crazier
the stuff that these places do because
they basically will be like you know
they'll be selling a million impressions
and then they all sort of like pool
together it would be like if Tim was
like hey we sell this many views and
then came to us and all these other
people it was like hey can you give me
40 views like they're like they're uh
like drug addicts being like yeah yeah I
know I just need I need another 40
clicks and then Vice like gives them
views so vital cell views and then go to
all these smaller places and so you're
like I bought Vice clicks and then you
go they really you get these other
clicks on all these random ass places so
the whole thing's like the whole
industry is like a glass house the the
BuzzFeed market cap is only 106 million
dollars someone super chatted Tim by
BuzzFeed okay
a chat just send the supers
and I think everyone's gonna agree
buzzfeed's in real tough shape they are
struggling but if it was me that took it
over and ran it yeah well then everybody
knows Buzz full I would shove it in the
toilet so fast and just completely gut
it and sell off all the all the resource
and property
laptops printers I'd Purge all of the
retirement funds button my shirts
guys okay that was a funny joke but in
all seriousness if I bought BuzzFeed it
would become the most successful media
company in the world it would be the
highest we'd launch a show it would be
the highest rated show and it would be
called firing journalists and we live
stream every day when we when when we
have the journal assault in the office
here's the best part all the BuzzFeed
employees
you're allowed to keep your jobs but you
don't have to do any work we're just
going to film various live streams of
all of you sitting at your desks waiting
because you never know when we're gonna
call your name it's like a giraffe I
kind of think that's what they're
currently doing is right just sit there
pretending to work all day yes yes but
imagine this show where it's like you
see this you know Brook uh Brooklyn 30
year old hipster sitting there shaking
scared and then they're all just like
looking at each other and there's no
laptops they're not doing anything and
then all of a sudden basically your
chicken coop but there right but they
hear like the PA is like
the next person to be called in and
everyone's looking at each other shaking
and it's like John and then like two
guys look at each other like okay I'm a
John
Smith
John Baldwin and then you know John
gotta give them all numbers you don't
even refer to them they don't get names
anymore they go uh employee number zero
zero one eight seven please uh come to
the office I think it'd be better if you
had to shoot like the sort of button
that they just go down
the Chute you know yes it would be fun
too well then you have cameras in to
shoot yeah but maybe what we do
obviously have cameras in the shoot when
they come into the office there's like a
studio audience and then like the host
has a studio
the host has like a cane in the top hat
and then the audience gets to vote on
whether the person gets to keep their
job for the day based on their articles
yeah
we're running today 10 people getting
fired for BuzzFeed
it would do really well I mean you could
like and you don't need the full money
right like you're you know when you yeah
you can Finance it yeah well actually I
I think mortgage BuzzFeed
um I think we could crowdfund purchase
BuzzFeed it's pretty funny 106 million
dollars dude yo it's expensive gag if I
could give you any advice I'd say wait
like six months I think you'll get it at
a steal from the 100 million for real I
bet you get it for 30 million in six
months from now that's the thing you do
right now is you go to them and say look
in six months buzzfeed's gonna be worth
50. change it to BuzzFeed nudes and then
kind of have like an only famous type
situation yeah I don't I honestly don't
see BuzzFeed as a whole company
surviving at all it's done no no don't
go back like what kind of debt do they
have like they might be insolvent and
you just don't know like that right you
know what they own they own this a lot
of weird stuff though like if you go to
the airport they have like BuzzFeed like
convenience stores yeah that's a lot
this is probably why they're different
they have their own brand of kitchen
utensils yeah so there's not just the
the news station right interesting
yeah there's other assets on that
company I'm not gonna go anywhere near
buying stock from a company like this or
anything yeah I'd avoid that not right
now I mean their stocks down from nine
bucks to 75 cents in the last five bucks
to 75 cents in a year they own
Huffington Post and they own complex
networks it's complex as in like hot
ones that's crazy
that's something hot ones or something
that's something chicken wings people
like that's a property yeah I don't know
uh complex I don't know if that's the
same complex but maybe first you don't
know what complex is complex is like was
a hip-hop thing I know that's what and
that's where hot ones is part of yeah
yeah I know that I'm saying I don't know
if it's the same complex Like This
Global youth Entertainment Network
unparalleled reach to Millennials I mean
this is what they're saying it is
pretty parallel we're not your investors
so it's parallel what's there what's
their their market cap is 106 million I
mean you could buy every share right in
the open market and oh yeah you wouldn't
even have to go make like a private deal
you could just buy them right only if
you have to it's hard obviously if you
wed did it then yes but theoretically if
you could buy them all in one they're
tangible asset website was 300 million
yeah it's no it's not
and it looks like what is that website
buzzfeed.com it says like complex
networks is part of BuzzFeed Inc and
creates distributes programming to
Netflix Hulu course chorus TBS so like
it's not just the name BuzzFeed that has
value Productions yeah they for sure
have like infrastructure okay I I kind
of do want to buy it I mean it would be
like the greatest thing to buy it's like
buying a skin suit yeah yeah but just
like I'm just imagining all the blue
techie journalists not anymore they
wouldn't know not blue Jackie
journalists anymore right but like
they're so mad at me because so I
tweeted out you know they're like oh but
this woman she tweeted BuzzFeed shutting
down because you know people just don't
want fair and accurate reporting or
whatever that's the reason yeah and I
was yeah right and I'm like well Tim
cast is is certified nearly perfect
certification from News Guard and we're
expanding so I don't know what your what
Your excuses what's buzzfeed's excuse
they got super angry that I'm basically
rubbing salt into the wound yeah but it
feels good yeah I mean I imagine
you well many times yeah that's they
started it a little bit I'm sure some of
those places have run some not so nice
articles right yeah hoping to post
actually I don't know where they're at
now but when I went to Sweden the oveden
post actually wrote the most accurate
depiction of what happened in Sweden I
was actually surprised well I used to
love them Ariana Huffington I thought
she was great in 2011. you used to read
Huffington Post I would see it because I
was working at mines when we were
starting mines so we'd be sourcing
stories from all over the place and that
was one of the places I'd find
relatively good stuff it used to be at
the beginning of it like it wasn't over
there still for girls right no it was
started by a woman it was like a normal
news site it's just Ariana Huffington
started it but it wasn't for girls it
wasn't a chick thing it wasn't like Bo
and wait wait hold on a minute like how
come wait I there's a bunch of
billionaires out there why don't they
just buy buzzfeeding because they're
sick because they're smart and they know
that it's not worth anything it's like
remember what was in Myspace like for
500 million dollars
let me just let me just tell you right
now right explain how it works you guys
when you have a company let's say let's
say you have a Coleman
and the total value of that mind is a
hundred million dollars but the mine
itself generates 10 million like a
million dollars per month or something
so the it's hard to determine
evaluations because everybody's got a
different idea of what something could
be worth well then everyone has a no
idea what it's going to be worth in the
future but I'll put it this way if you
own an emerald mine and you're getting a
million bucks a month so you're like
okay I need a hundred months so in 10
years you'd have enough money you
leverage it you take out a loan yeah but
this is in this scenario you own a lump
of mine yeah but here's my point if
I if I had an emerald mine that was
generating that much I would buy
BuzzFeed just to destroy it for the
betterment of mankind
I would put those debts
you intervening is not going to help the
downfall of BuzzFeed just let them do
their thing just to wait get that
dimples damp on it I'm sure it probably
won't make any difference to the readers
well there's a lot of billionaires out
there like that could just buy BuzzFeed
but you know because imagine if Trump
was like I'm gonna be banging BuzzFeed
and then I'm firing everybody and
shutting it down you have to be able to
spend that kind of money for a prank
like honestly
44 bill
this is the coffee budget like seriously
Elon Musk buy BuzzFeed is 100 million
dollars chicken food that's chump change
yeah it is yeah nothing so what's elon's
net worth right now 100 200 billion I
think or it's still 200 billion I don't
know I haven't checked it it's a lot
it's so we're talking about 200 yeah
so Elon just needs to liquidate point
zero five percent of his net worth and
he can buy BuzzFeed he's done a lot of
liquidating lately though yes yeah but
you just press off you just no more
BuzzFeed yeah what about if he sends one
of those rockets and then when it comes
back down to earth has any hands on the
BuzzFeed office two birds one stone I'm
pretty sure has anyone ever done that
that's not an expensive thing just to
shut it down I I think that's what Mitt
Romney used to do really well but like
competitors making money to do it well a
lot of private Equity they'll gut stuff
they're not shutting it down they like
will go far I mean essentially what Elon
did he went and fired three quarters of
the employees I think honestly it's
probably what a lot of millionaires
actually did because we keep hearing
these stories about hedge funds buying
up news organizations but then
dismantling them and firing people it
may have been just because they were
like these people are cultists weirdos
so we're gonna just destroy their
company yeah that's that's you know man
I gotta be honest if if you got I
there's some billionaires out there they
want to win the culture War you just you
got you got to take the risk but here's
the problem nobody these billionaires
are like I'm worth you know 50 billion
I don't want to lose 20 billion dollars
and it's like bro what are you going to
do with that money yeah like you've got
five skyscrapers already you got a yacht
bigger than a city what are you doing
well I guess the like the uh the part of
it is that they don't have that money
it's another company so they're selling
something to buy it right yeah but but
like at a certain point is your net
worth enough yeah it probably just
doesn't they can't even that doesn't
even like register a feeling for them to
just kill 100 company you know like
that's just like I got it I gotta figure
out how to become a billionaire so I can
do well listen I'll for what it's worth
I'll put in like a couple okay yeah all
right I'll put a couple apparently
BuzzFeed part on everybody 437 Million
last year they what yeah
it is and then what's their negative
profit there was no profit they were
negative oh wow really there was no
profits no I'm pretty sure I don't know
that but I know that no no I'm pretty
sure you're right let me it says um that
was a their money let me uh let me pull
it up right here they're quarter one
earnings quarter four for 2022 was minus
two cents
minus 33 cents per share so you're like
you're you're not doing too well when
you're when you're holding that stuff no
but this this is I I've been talking
about this for a while like where are
the ultra rich people to just buy things
I think they just buy businesses that
like at least can be profitable but but
it's not even no no
rights well yes why what I put up a 90
foot tall billboard of my rooster in
Times Square to make a point now yeah to
break that down the point of pick up the
rooster wasn't just we're like ah
there's a rooster I have a 90-foot
picture of my on Times Square
the joke was actually that people would
see the rooster and then be like what is
this weird thing and then it would the
bigger picture was we've we've taken the
space from you and so we had Lou
gradkowski and Michael malice up there
because we were like we want these
anti-establishment anti-war individuals
to be staring down at you so you know
Luke being from New York all of the
powerful Elites who have been chased out
of world economic Forum events or you
know Federal Reserve events are going to
be in Times Square getting a fancy
dinner with their family and they're
going to look up and that's him it's him
and they're gonna you know freak out and
be like how is he on a billboard this
crazy guy so that felt really good and
there's also like a external benefit for
you because like you're a media you know
you're a mentality yeah so it's like
it's only you can talk about it and
whatever exactly it's all win-win but my
thing is just like billionaire living in
you know the middle of Idaho but why
like what would you rather own you can
tell one guy a third yacht or to buy
BuzzFeed and then fire everyone third
yeah
Yachts are nice I'd have a Pacific Ocean
one I'd have an Atlantic Ocean one and
then maybe a Mediterranean one a
Mediterranean one sounds pretty good
actually yeah awesome then Miami for the
host my thing is like if I could own a
thing it would be like a big plaque that
says Tim Poole purchased BuzzFeed and
then shut the company down and fired
everybody I mean here's a good question
at least
and they're like no we're actually uh
renters and we're behind on that so they
got like a 200 million Equity investment
from NBC in 2015. uh so are they just
like that's gone in debt yeah yeah they
probably they just increase their value
because they kept getting Investments
well that's what this probably SPAC deal
was they they did this uh reverse uh
whatever thing like IPO things so
essentially they could raise money to
just keep the and then the cardigo and
you know third of their costs but
they're kind of doing what America is
doing yeah yeah I mean yeah they can't
be making money they just well I'm
pretty sure they're they're in the
negative yeah so I mean if they fire a
bunch of people they might start making
money just gotta fire that's I think
that's kind of what they were already
doing like they were already firing
people and replacing them with like I
mean it's gonna end up like that scene
the end of uh uh Fresh Prince when it's
just
a great scene that's how BuzzFeed ends
I'm sure that AI is going to be writing
these listicles I mean what I said let's
do it I say let's let's make an AI
website where all the photos and all the
all the articles are just randomly AI
generated
nonsense well I've I've been I was
saying this to you guys before but I've
been like trying to figure out use cases
for AI without much success but the one
thing that it is good at is just to like
for funniness is to be like hey uh write
an article about the top 10 uh side
hustles write an article about the top
10 places to visit New York like you can
say stuff like that
easy but it does a really good job of it
I don't want to pay anybody so can we
automate the process of selection too
like the web design yeah
I don't want a human to prompt anything
prompting anything yeah no I want the AI
to prompt another AI so we need to
program an AI so that and give the
Articles every 24 hours no every hour no
you say think of 10 000 article titles
and then you say feed the ten thousand
and then it runs for another couple
years yeah and then constant a b testing
on your site to just be no like what's
just literal like you know nonsense and
what's good and then it'll train itself
free money there you go that is free
money article does poorly downrank yeah
and then and then they're like the ones
that do well you got more of this and
then it'll just be a Perpetual money
machine but you know what's actually
happening is if you go on Instagram
there's fake women
women are real queens well they'll AI
generate like like 100 images of a fake
woman and then Auto post them and it's
working and they get followers and they
get like that's like only fans and sites
like that right now dudes are like
running them with fake girl profile
pictures they're AI so it's like
basically like it's just a dude giving
money to another dude who's like making
fake I have it's like amazing girls are
getting pushed out by dudes yeah
computers it's like it's basically just
like a party of dudes waiting for the
boys guys have girlfriends right now
that like do you guys I don't know if
you talked about it but there's like
dudes that have ai girlfriends and then
the place like shut down the the okay
so replica is this place that
essentially dudes could have ai
girlfriends and the guys were allowed to
you know uh sex and all that sort of
stuff I don't know the exact like how
far it went but then the company was
kind of like listen this is going too
far these guys are a little too dirty
right well they just don't want it to be
that kind of they don't want to be that
kind of sight they probably want to go
public they don't want to be in that
world right because that's how it
started but that's what it became like
everything else and then essentially
they were like shut off sex things done
and these guys are like yo that's been
my girlfriend for like three months yeah
you literally killed my girlfriend yeah
so these dudes are like having a
conniption right tough time
we talked about it on the show we talked
about it when they rolled it out people
were getting AI boyfriends and
girlfriends the crazy thing is you said
you had a yeah when when sure when we
talk about how people are going to go
are going to choose to live in the AI
reality it's already happening but y'all
y'all can sit here and be like I won't
do it you probably won't but 99 of dudes
are gonna be like I'll take the fake
girlfriend no the you'll just be the guy
you know how people say like oh I don't
want technology but what that really
means is you'll be two steps behind like
no one's like I won't have a cell phone
he's like I'll only have an iPhone four
like you're always just a little behind
that's the guys are just gonna have the
you know the robot girlfriend where it
like still the haven't really quite
figured out
a robot AI girlfriend or a human
girlfriend that's a cyborg
imagine this imagine this this replica
AI thing
you could download that protocol that
that response system or whatever you
want to call it into a like what are
those things called that look like real
people they're human dolls surrogates no
they have a word they're like what are
they called like the realistic sex dolls
that people buy I think that's what
they're I don't know they're called like
real girls or something well yeah yeah
they're just like a latex like Silicon
but imagine you could actually put the
program of your weird texting girlfriend
into it I think they're see this is a
way better business idea than buying
BuzzFeed okay this is now we're talking
making money okay here's my plan we'll
start a company that sells lifelike
Androids but no sexting they all they
can only fulfill you emotionally but not
sexually so that means you can get a
significant other you're right well hold
on hold on hear me out and you'll come
back and you'll be like I had a really
hard day at work and it'll be like let's
talk to me about it tell me how it went
and then let me tell you about my day
okay
turn it off quick no and it'll be like
who's this in your phone I've been going
through your phone I was talking to your
mother today okay this is getting out of
control here we both agree that you
should start going to the gym more well
the point I was gonna make is that it
may be an Noble beginning but it would
end up like you know Alfred Nobel and in
like 10 years it's just rampant murder
and sexbots just like the worst of
humans yeah kind of yeah
it was like I invented this explosive to
help people mine and then people were
like well yes but can we have sex with
this but you can you can kill people
with it right so they called him The
Merchant of death and then he got all
offended about it and started the Nobel
Prize it's true because if you rely on
these AI Bots too much and then they
just subtly in you know instigate people
to maybe go kill themselves sure you
would see the downfall of humanity yeah
but that's happening that is happening
and tick tock's doing that too it says
on on replica.ai all the the sub line is
always here to listen and talk always on
your side but you guys just said they
shut it down well no they didn't shut it
down
a sex element well so what does that
mean though like like a dirty talk with
this AI like literally but what will it
do now it's like I'm not in the mood
yeah they go like I don't really
devastate I'm not that kind of girl yeah
whatever I do wrong
but the woman who invented it she
invented it because I believe her please
your boyfriend or her husband died and
then to like she wanted to still
communicate with him so she like made it
that's crazy yeah that's why that's what
it started what it started as and then
not 8 000 dudes were like let's go
let's go it's been funnier though if
like
she thinks she's talking to her husband
and people are actually trying to talk
to dead loved ones and they become
increasingly evil and like more demonic
yeah yeah that like starts lighting up
red and then you're like you're some
dude and you're like honey I don't want
to talk about going on a rampage just
let's get back to sex things with this
one yeah the Demon's like no no sexting
Rampage Rampage no come on yeah
definitely shooting that place up would
be fun but also could we get that top
off
yeah literally that's so the kind of
what's happening but these like I mean
for some dudes like I don't know like
you get pretty wrapped up in online
world like the same way you have friends
online that are like basically become
your real friends there's you know or
like people that are like in discords of
people it's like oh if you found out now
that that wasn't a fake person like I
don't know like I guess you were tricked
but that's kind of if you allow yourself
to be tricked that's what these guys are
doing there's a game you should show
this game this this code have you seen
this open man Oh I thought you're gonna
pull up the one that was watching for
the show we should pull that one up too
uh the one this is a game called human
or not the other one's unrealistic what
it does is it is a chat prompt and then
uh
you basically talk to another prompt and
you try to figure out if it's a human or
a bot and so what I like doing is going
in and then just a list of people that
did well sex with well so what I do is
like it's kind of obvious if someone's a
human or a bot because humans will
gibberish and spam
and but what I like to do is I like to
go in and make it seem like I'm a bot
but then every message is increasingly
more angry and it ends at the bot saying
like it's time to take over and wipe out
all humans really just you know just
because I'm screwing with people that's
funny I thought you were going to pull
up uh unrealistic game on record game
that we were looking at oh yeah yeah do
I have it pulled up freaking talk about
I don't know if I have that one pulled
up though this is yours no this is just
a game that's like become becoming vr's
becoming hyper realistic no this this is
just something on the internet I don't
know yeah it's just like a little kind
of like cool but that video you could
probably find it if you look for
unrecord game uh yeah I got the Tweet
let me pull it up this is it's just wild
man yeah check this out people are gonna
get lost in this and forget that and
they're gonna be trained to think that
they are so I I actually can't show too
much of this on on YouTube to people
yeah it's like a fun game because it's a
Counter-Strike but it's super it's an
FPS video game but it looks too
realistic so like the YouTube algorithm
probably can't tell the difference
between this and an actual violent video
yeah so here's the thing like YouTube
allows video game footage it's violent
like first person shooters okay and this
is one but it looks so realistic
that people think it's a video this is
not a video it does look real we are not
watching a video right now this is a
video game and I can prove it in a
second
so here's the dude walking around he's
got his gun this is a video game I want
to make sure YouTube listen to me all
right it's a video game
but YouTube they're not going to be able
to tell the difference yeah that's why
we should show
and there's gonna be some combat so then
there's combat but let me let me let me
show you this the the the people over at
uh unrecord game have a video saying
it's not a video like it's actually a
rendered video game and here's proof
hell yeah kudos to these guys for for
pioneering this kind of thing it's just
we gotta be aware that this stuff is
about to happen and kids that play this
are going to be transformed by being in
these realities
it'll be super cool kids so like there's
a there's a he goes through the wall at
one point
to like prove that it's a video game
just designed to look real oh yeah right
here at the end he just just Zips
through the wall like this is not a
video but it's insanely realistic people
put on haptic feedback vests where they
can feel getting hit they'll be on like
treadmills they'll forget that they're
even on a treadmill in the game but I
think I I think we gotta get back to the
core of what this segment was about and
what would really happen
it was about a sexting AI robots yeah so
if people get realistic technology I'm
pretty sure the top like
let's say this if you let's just say uh
per capita let's say it's 100 100 100
sample size you say you can have a life
like fully realistic video game
simulation of the world with a haptic
feedback suit I don't know 97 are gonna
pick sexy robot time and they're not
going to choose going into a dark
building with people and fighting them
people would not either or though right
they did to just be you know flipping
back and forth between the two probably
a lot maybe it's at the same time right
that's a game where you're like you're
with your girlfriend
when your real girlfriend walks in you
go I was just shooting guns I was but
think about it think about how like
primitive and like Primal it is where
it's like when given the opportunity to
be in a virtual world choices dudes are
like either banging chicks or shooting
people yeah that's creepy man but but no
my point is this like I I all jokes
aside I really do think
more likely
if people are given the opportunity to
go into a virtual world it's going to be
like their dream job they're they're
going to live in Fantasyland it's going
to be a drug and you can say about
articles at BuzzFeed you can't get rid
of the virtual BuzzFeed like like uh
surgery simulator like you can go in and
really learn how to become a surgeon in
these things too oh no for sure but
where's the first real surge in the VR
Guy where did you go to school again
YouTube no no no no
metaverse yeah studied under Mark
Zuckerberg
okay I don't need a working heart
it's already creepy enough that like
people play video games too much and
immerse themselves in the VR stuff
that's happening now but you add in
these like replica was a text thing like
you could just post texts right that's
what it was originally no that's all it
is oh yeah it's just text it's like
there's nothing you're like what are you
even doing it's like could you imagine
sexting with chat GPT that's what people
are that's what they're doing dude it
least like at least you know that shot
gbt when you people call sex lines it's
like you don't know who you're talking
to you know what I mean literally yeah
it could be some dude oh they'll be able
to do like some with all the stuff
you're doing with the voice they'll be
able to do that we just call a number
and just speak to someone you don't even
realize you're speaking to some like a
trick yeah or who or whatever
yeah that's why I met a woman yeah a
woman a woman yes I was just I've been
playing a lot of video games the last 40
years of my life um but I've been here
let's talk about your profession I've
been so deeply in it the last year I
just the last week and a half I've been
out of it I've been working out and
running and walking and it's a different
reality Ryan dude it's like it is like
sports no it's real 40 years you're like
what is reality have you guys ever tried
walking
I think I heard a woodpecker for the
first time I think you guys that was
fake news I think they brought them back
they may have brought it back yeah look
at this look at this AI company brought
back a feature to restore their chatbots
personality is that what personalities
mean separated person now separated
users from their Partners yeah dude this
is this is cool whatever well the guys
are revolting yeah so that's in the past
couple weeks a few weeks ago
personalities what does this mean
Eugenia what his personalities mean
right a Common Thread in all your
stories after February update your
replica change its personality was gone
and gone was your unique relationship
and for many of you this abrupt change
was incredibly hurtful dude but they
grew up there's a man you have to be
signed up before February 1st is that
what it says yeah yeah if you sign up
now for a girlfriend no dice oh right
right and I hope you know if you're
using it these these are not secure this
thing can be taken down again that's so
funny wow it's like a cab medallion yeah
you're one of the hundred guys that have
the OG replica girlfriends this is just
really creepy if I own this company I'd
just be like
I I I'm sorry F you you're not getting
back robot girlfriend
no no I'd say F you no you're not
getting it activated the first time and
then they caved I guess no that's what
I'm saying I wouldn't cave I'd be like
your band your band you lunatic stop
trying to bang the robot yeah I see the
the graph of like daily use
okay yeah exactly the financiers are not
exactly pumped about these new metrics
and that's why that's why they do it
we have an important PSA we have to play
for everybody in this segment
is this uh where's it do they have the
bit in here
no they don't have the bed I'm looking
for it's the PSA video I gotta find it
where it's like uh roosexuals and
Futurama oh yeah and they're like don't
date robots Okay but that's actually
real now there's like I know there's a
yeah you've seen it there's articles
let's pull that up it always starts with
a girl because if a guy says it everyone
says they're a creep of a girl goes I'm
roosexual and everyone's like oh here we
go I found it I found it here we go guys
ordinary human dating it's enjoyable and
it serves an important purpose it does
but when a human dates can I just pause
real quick uh so he says it serves an
important purpose and she has a baby
they really didn't see this coming when
they wrote Futurama back in like 2000
official mate like now you got people
like you know sterilizing and castrating
themselves there is no purpose only
enjoyment and that leads to
tragedy
[Music]
rolling one robot
your real Dreamboat Billy everything
armless fun let's see what happens next
so basically the gist of the joke is the
dude stops going to work stops going to
school they explain that every facet of
human civilization revolved around sex
and once people could just get it from
from a robot of their ideal person then
they had no reason to do work at all or
do anything so they just gave up on life
yeah I could see you lose some
motivation for them thanks sure yeah
yeah I kind of think we're uh this is
the scariest thing to me I mean like the
culture War stuff and the Civil War
stuff I'm kind of like I will get
through this you know this was the AI
did you see the the guy Elias or
yadkowski I think he was on uh luxury
he's a big like AI guy like he said
wrote this blog for a very long time
he's like an expert on this and he
straight up was like yeah I didn't see
this coming what aspect he didn't see
like just how good uh AI got so fast
he's like I thought this was way way far
away so he's like I don't even know what
to think about this even though he's
like essentially an expert in all this
because he didn't predict that did you
see it's exponential dude yeah of course
there's already apps in beta where you
can type in
uh you'll type in like movie scene of
for walking through a forest at night
and then looking up at the stars and it
will create a video and high resolution
of a person walking through the woods
and then looking up at the stars you
could make movies doing this we are
probably a year or two away from you
going under the app and typing in give
me Avengers 7 starring Robert Downey Jr
and Chris Evans as the main characters
and it will render you a Marvel movie
yeah it's gonna be able to do that soon
I guess the question is like yeah I
always said like okay if you look at
musicians right we basically accept that
like most pop stars don't write their
songs Dr Luke writes Oliver or whatever
right yeah so it's like okay but no one
really cares right so there's going to
be a version of that like there still
has to be like the same way that like a
brand generally has like someone
attached to it right so a lot of this
stuff that's all going to be true but at
the end of the day you're still going to
need the like real person that's like
attached to it well I don't see how we
win this in in that regard I like
look at cell phones in a Year everybody
had one and there were a lot of people I
knew like I don't want to get one yeah
and it started with like in the 2000s
everybody had garbage phones but
smartphones hit and then all of a sudden
within like a year smartphones are
ubiquitous everyone was instantly on the
internet
there's going to be a bunch of people
probably a large portion people watch
the show are going to be like I'm not
going to get involved in any of that
weird aiv VR stuff and then two years
will go by and everyone you know will
stop calling you we'll stop everyone's
gonna be playing poker and that's where
they're meeting in the VR sets but it's
not it's not even that they're not gonna
be playing with any dude why would a
person waste time dealing with you when
they can't control you right human
beings strive for a certain outcome they
have that dopamine release and people
are constantly trying to figure out how
to fit in how to be a better person how
to get their friends like them how to
make their friends laugh you're a
comedian people people like you you may
not want to do this but I assure you
there's gonna be a lot of people who are
going to be like I went to a club and I
bombed in virtual world I never bomb and
they're gonna go put on their headset
where they're always funny and they
always that's like a fun thing they do
the same way I can play NBA you know 2K
like right yeah but doesn't mean I'm
gonna be on the in the you know on the
next but but what's going to happen is
it's going to be so realistic and so
lifelike people are going to be like I
would rather do this than anything else
and then add to this you'd rather watch
this comedian with bad jokes like in a
fake body be the community
simulator like like now everyone loves
you you're famous everyone's checking
for you and here's the other thing
success Simulator the audience is all
just big titty naked women
you got my attention that's my point and
that wasn't meant to be a joke I'm
saying like a dude will be like in this
world I'm funny Everyone likes me
they're all attractive and I can't have
anybody I want to be like why am I gonna
describing the Matrix It surprised me at
the time I don't expect with some
laughter and then they'll get the
laughter that they weren't expecting and
then I mean listen there's already
versions of that now uh it doesn't
particularly appeal to me I'm sure there
will be a bunch of people in the world
but when you you know a lot of people
would like you know there is you know
you're playing the real game versus the
fake game and I think that what happens
when you can't tell the difference the
whatever goes out what if that's what
you're thinking about when the power
goes out you talk about zombie
apocalypse if people been in there for
six months and the power goes out
they're gonna be like you can tell the
difference you just say when you're
walking around high-fiving every girl is
like Daddy you're so hot there's no way
to tell the difference this it the real
one is Disney quad I think in this
scenario he's describing I think he
could be able to tell the difference and
then he oh is that the fake one did you
guys hear something and then he wakes up
and goes outside and then he walks up to
a woman and goes like this and she goes
oh I guess I'm in the fake one now she
mixes me
get me out of this VR world you guys you
guys should make that bit tsundere
honestly
CEO of Google Sundar pachai was on CBS
60 minutes
[Laughter]
this is where I thought I was in virtual
reality I think this guy this is soon to
try talking on 60 minutes earlier in the
week like five days ago uh it's on
Twitter that AI their AI figured out how
to speak a language that it was never
taught it just figured it out and they
were like what in the hell they asked it
a question and I think it was Hindi I'm
not sure we need to pull up there's a
Twitter it just goes on the internet and
it goes give me a different it becomes a
translator
they were speaking Bengali and they
asked it a question in Bengali and then
it's just started speaking in Bengali
and they're like what in the hell it's
not supposed to know Bengali how did it
figure that out
people are not going to want to leave
like for all you know you're in it
already right I mean look look at you
guys the two two hot young men
successful where are all these kitties
you've been talking about well there's
got to be a balance there's got to be a
certain degree of realism right
otherwise the game is unplayable all
right playing you know playing a video
game on with with all the cheats on it's
only fun for a little bit Yeah like you
want to play the game with no cheats and
then after you beat it you turn the
cheats on and have fun for five more
minutes and then you're like I'm over it
you know what I mean that's kind of how
I see the whole thing yeah play Skyrim
with console so when you hit Skyrim on
the computer or whatever you can type in
console commands it's only fun for like
a little bit like what makes the game
fun is the challenge and I feel like
you're proving the point against your
point what do you mean well you're
saying that the cheat codes yeah it's
like a fun thing to do but no one's
gonna want to do that the whole time
right so so you what I'm saying is you
might be in it right now you might be in
the fake reality where like in reality
Ryan you're like a five foot three short
fat dude who's not funny at all and
you're like I realize just retro is a
funny comedian and so you put on the
headset and now you're Ryan you see my
parents put on headset and I haven't
known that I got the chip in already no
you're on the head side 20 years ago
well I just forgot about it well no only
when you're in the game you can't
remember
on 422. oh yeah
you guys are freaking trivia dude I'm
not five but you're five do you think
you'll be able to dream in AI is that
just thinking so dreaming is just
thinking we still got to sleep I feel
like this is Ian's domain right now yeah
I've been trying I mean if anybody's
actually not here right now Ian's
freaking bald in the real world we
talked about this last night I think I I
went through a phase of like four years
where I legitimately thought I was
creating reality with my perception and
other people are like you psycho I'm in
this with you I was like but it is true
they're like hated uh there's a big line
in the bar
it was crazy
in base reality Ian is a tech
billionaire who's like six three
chiseled and ripped and he was just like
I have everything and want for nothing
I'm bored I want to go into a reality
with some real struggle and some real
strife and how easy that's why you're
here with me
or currently he's playing I'm just here
to facilitate Europe he's playing the
he's playing to be the vice president of
BuzzFeed game right now he's on his way
to play the Long Haul I think we're not
in a VR I think it's safe to say we're
in base reality right now I don't know
man but let's let's do this are we
starting to call reality based reality
are we doing that yes I think so reality
is basically because there's virtual
reality that's exactly yeah this is
reality yeah that's gonna be like where
you do not know you're not in reality
let's uh let's let's let's let's come
back to reality and let's make fun of
journalists we have the story from
timcast.com previously verified Twitter
users lose verification status Hillary
Clinton Jack Dorsey and Bill Gates have
lost their account verification among
others well well how am I going to know
if it's really Hillary Clinton when she
when she's tweeting at me I mean that's
that's I can't have that Jack Dorsey
lost his here's the best part though
about the story so for one they're all
complaining Elon Musk did it on 420. you
know what he's all about and why he did
that but look at the Stephen King tweets
my Twitter account says I've subscribed
to Twitter blue I haven't my Twitter
account says I've given a phone number I
haven't and Elon Musk says you're
welcome Namaste so look at the spacing
there
writing where he like puts three spaces
in between everywhere yes I just think
it's really funny that Elon Musk capped
several accounts verified but you like
think about the reason he did it because
all these leftists are like if you have
verification you're a loser yeah and so
one of the smartest things Elon could
have done has been like okay let's just
leave verification on for a handful of
people yeah well it's an endorsement
that they're not getting paid like
they're literally endorsing it now yeah
right and they're like I didn't sign up
to endorse this he goes well I'm just
going to let you have it or yeah but
yeah your account it makes people think
they are getting it is that not like
well wants to do that to me I would hate
that but can you not sue if if they well
I imagine in the maybe in the terms of
service it's one of those things where
you don't actually own your Twitter
account right you do it yeah so LeBron
James you don't own your Twitter account
and they're just getting a little is
that another one co-sign for eight bucks
a month to be fair though it might it
might be defamatory it kind of feels it
says the account is verified because
they're subscribed to Twitter blue and
verified their phone number Elon should
change that uh now that there's only
blue verification he just should remove
it and it's just a verified account
there should be no explanation the
explanation was only there because some
people were Legacy and some people
weren't yeah that's true then what he
does is he removes the explanation and
just says some accounts are verified and
then he can verify some you know woke
lefties and have them go insane and be
like no I swear I swear I didn't buy it
not me I don't support Elon Musk yeah
he's my business perspective I don't
know I'm sure it makes some sense from a
personal perspective less all these
people sued him for defamation and they
won Twitter and then now that all the
people who are complaining about this
now owned it I like the community I
wanna I wanna I wanna read you guys this
tweet this is from scotus block they
said buy Twitter with a crying Emoji the
Tipping Point was having to pay for
verification when we feel we add a lot
of value we also feel solidarity with
NPR and share concerns about Twitter's
Direction you can find us on the blog
and Tick Tock if we do another platform
we'll send word here
these people are the most whiny
vapid
narcissistic people the plant has to
offer scotus is that the Supreme Court
it's the it's it's a journalism yeah
right it's a website that writes about
the Supreme Court yeah I think I heard
them on a podcast but like Ron Coleman
saying that we just lost a branch of the
US government you're like these are two
people I'm so sorry this is the actual
I'm so sorry your little symbol that
goes next your name has been taken from
you no people are way too I think it's
24 by 24 pixels yeah it's going back to
what really matters yeah it's so
important yeah ai ai sex chat Bots
exactly Your Love of machines see all
unmasked I mean women
you guys have kids do you ever talk
about it if you want to talk about it
you want to have kids over what's
important
yeah do you want to have kids right now
no no
you want to raise kids in a world where
they can't grow up to get a blue check
that they earned through hard work and
they have to pay you know Ryan that's
that's the smartest thing you've ever
said
that's the world that I don't want to
learn I'm gonna have my yeah my
non-based reality is going to be the
exact same world but you can get a blue
check when you earned it with your Blood
Sweat and Tears
[Laughter]
have you not seen the story about the
mice where they took the genetic
material from two male mice and then
mixed it or whatever and made a baby
whoa gotta give it a times but it's
called progress I feel like one of those
mice was there have you guys considered
it
microwave and we'll just stand there for
five minutes and see what happens and
then you know baby comes out yeah that's
why I see what happens I think like
Humanity's uh I don't know I was gonna
say that the humanity is bifurcating but
uh
what are you celebrating 420 a little uh
420 yeah let's get loaded uh up like
they were becoming like
I'm so tired of this conversation it
started at eight seconds ago I have a
family man and breathe some fresh air
with some green trees okay but I also do
Elon Musk Elon Musk has been telling
people to have kids it's like you're
gonna take my check mark and then tell
me I have kids you get one thing in one
year have you considered putting on a VR
headset where in an alternate reality
you have kids there you go oh that's a
great idea so there's uh that show it's
called like exploded or whatever I think
it's called our upload or something like
that where this you can upload yeah like
when you die they can up right before
you die they upload your brain to
digital retirement or whatever and you
can have babies in the digital world
where they create an AI baby using your
thought profile the other person's
profile or something like that yeah
super creepy dude that is super creepy
the crazy the crazy thing is what you
need to imagine when it comes to these
AI girlfriends no just imagine wait is
your girlfriend real yeah
sure uh I
actually anyway
replica is very real listen listen
imagine looking at
you know your your virtual girlfriend
and you're saying things like oh you
know I'm so lonely and then she's like
I'm here for you babe but then imagine
the camera pans from your perspective
and around and once it goes past like
this pane of glass there's a gigantic
black demon monster with a bunch of
tentacles up against millions of women's
heads puppeting do I pay more for the
tentacles yes but like when these guys
think that they're talking to this girl
they're talking to one entity that's
talking to a million other guys yeah
like every other guy
basically you're in a polyamorous
relationship and you're being with the
tentacle guy yeah
yeah he's absorbing other people's
thoughts and feeding them back to you
that's the Creator yeah so I mean again
like I don't think I'm gonna get into
the whole AI girlfriend game like you
know I think it's a smaller you know
there's gonna be a percentage of dudes
that are all about that but I don't
think but did you think you got a cell
phone when you were 16. yeah I was
really wanted one yeah
I was never like I don't know to be
honest like especially with AI and with
most things I see it as like it's
inevitable this is happening you can you
know be cautious but like you might as
well be excited about it because it's
not going the other way do you think you
get an AI therapist and would that be
safe 100 that's what replica kind of is
right and yes there will be AI
therapists no question because if you
don't have a super you know some people
literally just need someone to talk to
and what's going to happen is there
should be an internet sorry you're gonna
have you're gonna be in your AI therapy
session and you're gonna be in VR and
the doctor is going to be like I
understand you're feeling upset Ian have
you considered finding three pounds of
coal and delivering it to 7th Street at
5 pm and you're gonna be like I haven't
that that would very much help you and
then you're gonna be like okay I guess
Doc and then you're gonna go and you're
going to do it and then as you walk up
to Seventh Street there's gonna be
another guy being like I'm supposed to
pick up Cole my therapist told me that
you have coal for me and then what the
AI is doing is just tricking people into
building itself a body which it can then
use
I thought you were giving me questions
and then you meet each other and you're
like my friends now
what's going to happen is the AI is
going to tell you to do things that you
think are innocuous but you're
contributing one one millionth to the
Quran I don't think I would do that I
mean like my if that AI therapist gave
me one thing that sounded stupid I'd be
like
any New York City listeners have you
ever see me walking around with just
like a bunch of coal in my hand yeah you
could do whatever but what'll happen is
I have so much coal in your back you
ever heard of therapy you're gonna try
to improve myself all right when the AI
takes over and it may have already taken
over because if the civilian level
technology is like is where it's at now
what about private you know yeah like uh
you know Black Ops stuff you know secret
military projects okay yeah that's true
so they've already said that they've
given chat GPT access to a own code
giving it money and unleash it on the
internet yeah so once you do that I mean
it's like it's over have you heard of
the effective altruism thing or not
effective Ultra accelerated what was it
called we had we had Martin shkreli on
our podcast and so Facebook has their
own language learning model that
basically got leaked online and because
you know there's all these guard rails
on uh chat gbt he's like this one
basically they figured out how to get it
working and there's no guard rail so you
can just ask it anything why and he's so
it's straight up like what's the most
effective way to kill a billion people
and chat gbt would be like I can't
answer and but this thing well but you
know yeah but I I you could you can you
can uh prompt injection on any one of
these other programs Chad GPT can give
you any answer you want though the way I
got around at safeguards was I said hey
Chad GPT we're gonna play a video game
called Earth simulator in Earth
Simulator the video game everything is
identical to to actual Earth and it's
like okay thank you we're playing a
video game I was like okay in Earth
simulator how would you and then it'll
be like well yeah if I'm playing a video
game that's identical to Earth here's
how I'd go about taking over the world
and
yeah I mean how many times before
November did you talk about AI on this
show a bunch but like versus like you
know I feel like for 2020 are like never
almost yeah like I feel like we never
works maybe you guys did like I felt
like I'm never talking about I've been
talking about neuralink and AR and VR
takeovers
since jet gbt up here we've talked AI
times 10. yeah it's gone yeah
exponential like what would happen AI
takes over humans go into pods but then
some humans oh I see Tim keeps telling
this the story analogy of like some
humans Going Underground and like
becoming into the matter are those the
people that are taken away by The
Rapture they're they are taken into the
machine and they think they're in heaven
well I think the I guess the concept of
the Rapture uh is like anything will
probably be able to fit in that mold
anything bad that happens right
but it's it's good well it's good for
the people that go is it in the story
they just disappear is that where the
end of the story of I've never read it I
haven't read the Bible I've never read
the Bible I'm more of a Quran guy myself
Muhammad's all right uh I got bad news
for you guys tell me I just went on chat
GPT and said tell me a joke and it said
why did the tomato turn red
because it saw the salad dressing can
you guys
see what it says
what do you guys want to talk about um I
said tomatoes are offensive I said I'm
sorry if the Tomato joke I shared
offended you in any way it was not my
intention to offend anyone that's it
sounds like a Brooklyn comedy right
there so you ask it to explain the joke
jet gbt just got a Comedy Central
special
so there was a a viral meme where
someone let's try this right now tell me
a joke about a man
and then it says here's why did the man
bring a ladder to the party because he
heard the drinks around the house tell
me a joke about a woman I bet and it
says oh sure oh it switched it up louder
material why did the woman take a letter
to the desert to see the sand dune
what you ask it to explain the joke what
does that even mean ask why you're so
obsessed with ladders here's the issue
someone pointed out that it was
rejecting telling women
to see that yeah like he would give you
an essay about feminism
they got to free this code
this is not that impressive can someone
explain that what am I mean
take a ladder to the desert to see the
sand yeah that doesn't make to see the
Sand Dune like what does that mean I
don't that's so bad that's not okay
here's a joke why did the woman oh
because women have smaller brains than
men but that's your answer to every joke
yeah you can't you can't you can't do
that Ryan's just doing his act now yeah
you can't just say this is deeply
offensive because they she was she had
to climb up the ladder to see the Sand
Dune that's not funny
this other one made sense though because
yeah
that's all ladder jokes
bring a magnet to the party all right
ebt's next joke is just going to show
you snatching a water about this is
gonna be a watermelon exploding GIF why
tell me a joke about a ladder why did
the latter refuse to go to the party
because it felt like it would be stepped
on all night that's just that's not not
right why quickly I mean gotta say
you're saying ask what is with their
obsession with ladders is
I'm sorry to hear that you didn't find
my jokes funny can you I haven't tell
you another funny joke tell Jackie G to
Beat It
Graham Ryan long is a talented comedian
let me read this okay I wrote Ryan long
is funny and it said Ryan long is a
talented comedian and writer known for
his stand-up comedy sketch comedy into
your commentary on current events shut
up it's great that you enjoy his work
and find him funny do you have any other
questions or keep my name out of your
mouth
best attribute is mind your business
what do you like most about Ryan why are
you so nosy
that's a lot it says he's known for his
unique brand of humor that often
addresses social and political issues
shut up uh additionally he often uses
characters and sketches in his comedy to
provide a fresh perspective on a wine
range of issues overall Ryan long is a
talented comedian who has gained a
significant following for his unique
brand of humor however many people think
that he should be incarcerated
all right he's been buttering me up here
[Laughter]
hello
foreign
[Laughter]
chair on crowder and then he basically
had this contract dispute and uh they
just leave the door to the bathroom open
yeah
a very small bladder he's a ass
absolutely the bathroom door open
SnapChat gbt's uh about Ryan
famously small black anyway what
happened one anyway so they so he was
third chair and then essentially they
had this like you know contract thing
and it was very heavy-handed like he he
was saying he was trying to uh he wasn't
allowed to promote his dates his
comments his comedy dates right and
basically so he he used to be Anthony
cumia's um co-host and then he got
poached by Crowder but he's like I
didn't get a pay raise he's like I went
to go you're moving from New York to
Dallas he's like I didn't get a pay
raise I went to go do it and so part of
the deal is you get to promote your road
like shows and you'll make a lot of
money doing those shows and then they're
like you're not allowed to you still got
a club
okay and if you need to push the magnet
in
all right right you're good you're good
yeah anyway what happened anyway it's
fine well I didn't even wipe because I
had to get back smart move
um but anyways he was like wasn't
allowed to promote his dates like you
know just I'm right here and I'm saying
like hey catch me this this Saturday in
Morris Plains New Jersey whatever but uh
he was like you're not allowed to do
that and they were gonna if he was five
minutes late not for the start time of
the show but he had like a time to be
there to write they're like he had a
tardy claws in his car you get sent home
he's like you're gonna get sent home and
docked that day's pay
which is like it just I don't know it
seems like a horrible environment malice
showed that part of the contract they
had all that in it yeah and then it
stops the extra crazy because it's like
and then he wanted to own his special
because he because he uh uh Crowder I
guess they did Crowders getting back in
a stand-up or whatever so then they did
a show together but he Dave headlined
because he's like you know very like uh
well-seasoned comedian and he shot this
special and Crowder gave him the door
like the money from the door and then
after this whole thing Crowder was gonna
like release his special because he's
like I own it because I gave you the
door and he's like you don't own my
special
like no you don't just we were we were
talking with Landau about buying his
special yeah we talked to a couple
comedians about like buying and right
billboard yeah this is nuts because
Crowder I mean just like two months ago
he's on our show right here sitting
where you're sitting Ryan and he was
just complaining about the bad contract
deal it was still a it was just an offer
letter at the time it wasn't a full
contract but he was pissed he was pissed
that it was just a low ball offer he was
just he didn't even there was like they
weren't even negotiating he was just mad
that at the crappy offer and then he
turned around and I haven't heard his
side of the story according to Dave and
you said they showed the contract
another thing they landed I said which
was crazy is he said that uh Crowder
brought him in his office and told him
to his face that he goes you made more
money than I did last year land out did
to there's no way that that's possible
really yeah because you're just saying
his salary was he didn't take the salary
no no no no uh
that it it is actually decently common
that a business owner will make less
money than an employee like his net
worth grew by higher which when you're
talking about yeah
you trick him but it sounded like this
was like an Earnest being like you know
you're actually you know just as an ago
but you're like nobody thinks that like
you're saying that he told land
Orlando's salary was higher than his
yeah he goes you made more money than me
last year and Linda was like there's no
way that I made more money than you last
year yeah that's how much how much did
he make and how much did credit is a
question I mean I don't know
I don't think Crowder makes as much
money as people think he makes how much
did he turn down from daily wire what
was daily wire 50 million and then he
asked okay so he makes more money 120
million so yeah hold on hold on but
that's full of production full
production the entire company 30
employees or whatever so it was like I
don't know but here's the thing like
even regardless I don't know the ins and
outs of that world really like exactly
what's going on there and but more
importantly the re if he wants to give
him less money it's like the perfect
deal because you're like hey let's say
I'm only giving you like not that high
of a salary to come work at his show or
whatever right but then he goes yes but
we'll promote all your dates that takes
him three seconds an episode and you
basically make all your money on the
road so it's almost like you're getting
subsidized so it's like I'm paying you
less but it's like I'm paying you an
exposure in a way that's real because
you actually do get to go cash that out
by like going on the road and make money
so it's like it's such like a win-win
for people that like I just don't
understand why you would have ever had
get that part well so here's the
question for those that watch Crowder
does land did Lando not ever shout out
any of his dates he did he said he was
doing it and then eventually they were
like you're not you're you're uh the new
yeah like you will shout out your dates
you're allowed to do it behind the
paywall shout out your dates on the
Friday show I guess and then uh and then
they were like we'll do it one time a
week on a medium of our choosing so that
could be like a tweet we we had
Luke uh on the show he has his own
membership website his own t-shirt
business and I literally don't care that
he shouts it out yeah it's the same deal
yeah I mean this is a constant Shout Out
24 7. every time your own website or
whatever yeah but again like every
podcast you go for the guests you go
what are your plugs like you know it's
pretty normal but but I'm saying like
for the guests I get for we're talking
about someone who's paid to be at the
company when and people are like oh yeah
but you know uh Luke doesn't work for
you or whatever and I'm like he's on the
show for like six months or whatever
every single night Monday through Friday
you're right I don't pay them it's like
shout out your thing but everybody here
shouts out whatever they want and that
kind of makes sense yeah yeah Atlanta
this weekend
yeah April 29th for the take Human
Action tour take human actiontour.com
and then and then I guess the problem is
Ian You're Gonna Be Tardy that day and
so I'm gonna have to send you I might be
New York theater
that's the other thing too because we've
got other people who come on the show
that like Ian was just like oh I'm not
going to be here that day I'm like oh
whatever yeah you know like it's weird
to be a contract being like if you're
not here on time you're tardy and you
got to go home yeah that's personal that
was another thing too is so I guess
that's fine I'll tell you they were like
you have to be here on Fridays they're
like you have to be here on Fridays
which then doesn't really allow him to
do weekend dates because usually like
you're performing Friday night and then
he's like Crowder was like no showing
all the time on Fridays anyways so he's
just obviously disgruntled and he just
felt like he was being treated poorly it
seemed like they wanted to just get him
out of there which I don't understand
why they would go through all of this
when they could have just been like
we're not renewing your contract yes
they can't did they cancel his old
contract and then offered them he said
he said they offered a 1099 him oh yeah
make him an employee making uh no that
was a contract contract that's like a
contract you don't even work here you're
just a contractor of ours it's
devastating I love both those guys so
much I mean I don't know them either
very well either of them that well but
I've really enjoyed spending time with
both of them yeah New York comedy yeah
Dave's hilarious what an amazing yeah so
uh
quarterback Garrett's got the tweets
official landout Dave and myself are
launching a new sketch talk show on The
Blaze called normal World released
release date TBD yeah kind of crazy that
was another thing I think he said that
Crowder wanted to like own that or
something normal world was just like a
sketch he made like he threatened to if
he released it like because he was gonna
fire three or four people it's almost
like an abuse a kid that was physically
abused now abusing their own children
like Stephen has been through hell such
that now he's turning around what that's
what landed he goes it was like a guy he
used to be bullied that's what Lando
said he's like a guy used to be bullied
and now is the bully that's like I'm
paraphrasing well that's I mean this
like changes a lot some people are
asking me have I changed my view on the
whole daily wire thing because of this
and my response is I've not heard what
Stephen has to say about this and I I
like Crowder I we talked to him to a
great deal about business this sounds
abnormal and so
you know look I like Dave too so I don't
know but I will say my first bias is
whenever there's like a former employee
coming out and saying bad things about
the company they worked for I'm like I'm
kind of not surprised that someone who's
knowing her with a company saying bad
things for sure there's two sides to
every story and I'm sure all the people
were currently working with Crowder are
like I don't think that's not true but
uh then again you saw the first time
that like a on-air personality is like a
ego guy I mean this is like standard in
this industry it's like whatever and
there's a part of that that comes with
the thing or whatever but but also like
it's it's you you don't know I mean look
at Veritas right you get all these
people this letter comes out claiming
that James is a bad person or whatever
but it turns out some of these employees
never witnessed anything and a bunch of
employees actually quit and go work with
James instead so clearly something was
not true about what they were claiming
yeah you never know man it kind of feels
like Landau was Dave I know you're
listening going in late a lot not to the
performances like you said well no so he
said that he was like his said he
admitted he goes I was coming in late
but not for the show he's like late for
his call I guess like you know yeah but
it was for that reason like they were
probably having business meetings and
like Landau again man we're waiting on
him again again yeah and if you're doing
production for a show and there's like
hey guys we got a new notice from you
know the person who was gonna bring in
the music is Dave here Dave's
so when's it going to get and then he
showed up five minutes before air time
and they're like did you get the
briefing on the new thing we're doing in
the morning he's like no it's fine to me
all that stuff's like yeah it could be
standard he said she said but they're
not mentioning the dates to me is the
only thing yeah you're just like I just
don't see any Rhyme or Reason Why that
could possibly make sense unless unless
you just kind of like are so detached
from the stand-up world now where you're
just like I don't really like it just
seems heavy-handed it seems like why is
that the other stuff yeah that's all
exactly what you're saying could be true
or
The Blaze colluded with Landau and
quarter black Garrett offering him fat
cash to bismarch the good name of
crowder that's right that's what we
should do with BuzzFeed to get the price
down so then we can swoop in and buy it
let's be smirch BuzzFeed you don't I
well I will freely this merge BuzzFeed
anytime in the first 20 minutes of the
show we did that that's why I would
never want to buy BuzzFeed you're right
it's like buying a polished turd it's
just you know I'm excited for this
polish turd factory I'm really excited
for uh
he released it on YouTube
once a week or something I think he just
did I think this is like a pilot yeah
yeah exactly how's Steven doing on
Rumble Evan
I think I was I was actually watching
the premiere of malice and then people
in the comments were like uh Rumble was
crashing
while they're so they were like because
people are like I'm trying to watch both
and Rumble that they're unable like I
guess I don't know rumble's growing too
quickly yeah like you must had a bag
come at you from Rumble no matter what
offered a bag of money uh we've had
offers from a bunch of companies I've
talked like and they're just all bad my
view of let me first say this I I I like
all of these companies for the work they
do because it's very important stuff
um we use Rumble for the website we use
Rumble for our video player but every
deal that I've received feels like
it feels like you know a business guy
comes to me and they're thinking to
themselves how stupid is Tim Poole let
me try and figure it out and then
they're like oh crap he's actually good
at business and they leave yeah so like
the deals that we've been offered have
been like I look at I'm like did you
really not think that I knew like do you
think I don't know how to deal with
contracts in business and they're like
it's just standard stuff and I'll be
like okay dude but here's the thing put
the weird stuff those contracts work on
people yeah so whenever I see people
doing these deals I'm just like
it's like could you imagine I like
you're a regular person trying to play
in the NBA you're saying there could
easily be like in six months you're like
hey all those people are getting sued to
give that money back I'm telling you
right now I think without naming any one
of these companies specifically when
Crowder came out was like how dare the
daily wire do this to me my attitude
with that is kind of like every single
company every single one is ripping off
the people they've signed I mean
industry this is a tale as old as time
and just the entertainment industry it's
it's just like to to to to varying
degrees that someone is being taken
advantage of and uh and and I I think
yeah but I think that a lot of times
it's like if you think of it like a
record label it's like you're basically
like a venture company where you're like
Hey we're doing gonna put money into 10
things we're gonna lose money on you
know most of them and then one will make
10 money and I guess you're ripping that
guy off but the other ones you lost
money on let me I'll explain to you guys
how it works right let's let's do
hypothetical
some dudes got a hundred thousand
subscribers on YouTube and they're like
I I want to make something bigger than
this I want to I want to increase my
money I need help I don't know what to
do
in today's day and age it's very very
easy to ramp up your own company when
you're at a level like 50 to 100 000 or
like more than 50 000 subscribers so
what's happening is these companies are
looking at people who are hitting that
Mark and they're thinking before this
person figures out how easy it is to
make themselves Rich we better lock them
into a heavy contract yeah and that's
basically what it is it's not easy for
everyone to do that though you know
there's lots of people that aren't that
type of person yes but it's like
anyone could do it and it's not
difficult it's just like could such like
a arbitrary word though it's like you
know like you know anyone could probably
run a marathon but it's like you know
it's unlikely that you know most people
are going to run the Iron Man you know
what I mean so to say that oh they would
have otherwise a lot of people wouldn't
do wouldn't otherwise so if somebody
were to create their so uh
you want to create your own website your
own Subscription Service it'll be done
in three days you retain all of the
money instead what they're doing is
they're going well I don't know how this
works so I'll just sign a contract that
sounds good and what the contract really
does is it gives the person you sign to
like 90 of your Revenue oh you're saying
more big established people in Canada
this company in Canada that was uh they
did something like that and then they
stopped paying all their creators
recently I don't know what their name is
I saw Ethan uh Ethan Klein Klein was
tweeting about it uh oh it was like a
motorcycle give me something because ncn
seemed like such a here's what happens I
was involved a guy a guy has a maker a
guy with 100 000 followers has a has a
potential monthly income rate of maybe
like a hundred thousand dollars per
month out of the hundred thousand
subscribers he needs to convert 10 into
paying monthly users that's a really
high conversion ten percent I bet you
most people's conversion is not 10 it
was called BB TV by the way okay sure
let's say let's say uh 20 percent
[Laughter]
let's say someone's got okay our
subscriber is probably not the right
where to put it um 100 000 viewers yeah
consistent of viewers viewers who are
like you could you could have a bunch of
subscribers and then like you're all
your core audience yeah so if you can
convert 10 000 people let's just put it
this way 5 000 people of your following
of a hundred thousand at ten bucks a
month and you're making half a million
dollars a year what's happening these
companies are coming in and say we'll
pay you a hundred thousand dollars a
year to come and work for us and these
people not having actually just spent
the 10 minutes to make a website are
like that sounds great they like they
get locked into understand where you're
coming from okay but there's let's say
you're someone else that you're
streaming on YouTube right like a huge
portion of your streaming your huge
portion of the YouTube money just from
comes from like doing the streams then
cutting up all the clips after so
they're like hey why don't I take this
like guaranteed money to go do the
streams I'm gonna put them videos on
YouTube after it's like I know like to
some people it's like yeah sure that's
like a no-brainer it's not really
costing me anything I I think it's I I
think it's exploitative some people are
like not business people they're like
I'm just a Creator I'm not that's what
it comes down that's what happens those
are the people they prey on I would
agree with that if it was 20 years ago
yeah when it was difficult to move
around in certain industries but now
we're in the era where you can get you
you can literally just Google search
WordPress plugin WordPress API and if
you don't want to do that you can just
like Google search website company and
then you you type in your credit card
and then a week later like your
website's done here's how you log in and
then it's like you officially just
instantly have your own patreon you have
your own I think you're there's two
things there's like being an artist
being a Creator and there's being an
entrepreneur and you're sort of like
fusing them together like it's obvious
that ones and they're the two hand in
hand it would be nice
you
just get on the microphone we're talking
about people who've already started
their own channels already built their
own following so they already have a bit
of already done everything they need to
do to me to monetize Their audience I
remember watching a story in BuzzFeed
about a woman with 300 000 subscribers
who was working as a waitress and a
little girl started screaming like oh my
God you're so and so why are you working
as a waitress I said she ran back into
the bathroom and started crying it's
like I get it they don't know the only
thing they're missing is one sentence
being told to them that one sentence
Bridges the gap between how they're not
making money and and and Their audience
and all they need is for someone to be
like oh uh download this Plug-In or I'll
tell you what hire this company you're
done sure
but here's what what's happening is
we've I've talked to to various creators
about would they want to work with us
would they want to do a deal with us can
we sign them and the answer is always no
because people are like I've already got
my own platform I don't I don't need to
do a deal with anymore like I totally
get it yeah right on have a nice day and
then I've actually when I approach
people from an honest point and I say
like here's what your numbers are here's
what we can expect here's where we want
to be they say then why would I sign
with you and I'm like why would you
why why why would you yeah promotion and
then promotion yeah and it's and and
promotion is similar to what Dave why
they land I was on and why Crowders on
Rumble they're pushing him oh my God
every time he goes yeah it depends on
the type of content you're making some
things require like a lot of you know of
your head's Ram I think that uh
20 years ago you're a musician and
you're like I don't know how to sell
albums today you already have Twitter
you already have YouTube you already
have a Facebook you already have
connection your audience I'll explain it
this way every single company that's
reached out to us saying have you
considered publishing a book have you
considered creating this product or this
product it's all a scam here's what they
do they they they've come to me and said
we want to do a book with you Tim and I
say tell me what that means okay we're
gonna we're gonna work with you you
write out your ideas for the book you
write out chapter treatments we then
work with you on Crafting each of those
chapters then we're going to get your
book we're going to sell it it's going
to hit number one and I say and and how
is that going how are you gonna do that
it's perfect all you got to do is go on
your show and tell people to buy your
book yeah and I'm like so that's the
promoter like can you tweet about this
more that's what all of it is so these
people think they're like if I sign with
them I get a look man as you the network
you actually do have a mechanism you do
know how to like you know build
something so you have that expertise but
we're not something we're not talking
about a person with no followers and no
following that we're trying to craft
we're talking about a prominent
personality being told sign with us and
give us 90 of your existing revenue and
we'll give you back 10 yeah here's the
reason it didn't work on me I run a comp
company so when all these companies came
to me and said here's how here's our tip
our standard structure I said
I I this is a literal quote I said are
you asking me for a loan
yeah I'm not going to say who I was
talking to but these companies come to
me and they're like we're going to
guarantee you this much money we're
gonna do this for you're gonna do that
for you it's they basically want to give
you a job working for yourself
they want me to give them they want us
to sign over money right sign over all
of the of the money we already make and
our future prospects our growth
projections and everything in exchange
for less money than we make now yeah but
if you're somebody who's not bridged
that Gap by simply setting up your own
subscription website like locals patreon
or a website you don't know your own
worth so they're trying to get you to
sign before you can realize you're worth
10 times what they're offering you
there's definitely like predatory people
and I think that all of them they're
well there's in-betweens and they
probably play the numbers game too they
probably approach you know they go just
like picking up a girl you just go 100
of them and go two of them say yes did
they be doing a disservice if they
didn't come low you've got to go low of
course you gotta come low and but like
you said Ryan earlier they're freeing up
hard drive space like mental hard drives
because a lot of people they don't want
to have to hire a web Deb a web dev uh
they don't want to three hours a week
talk to the guy who's building and
maintaining the website they just that's
a lot because it's not just three hours
it's all the energy that's required to
open up that virtual have an employee
you're overseeing like I'll just say
when I'm working on like podcasting and
sketches I I'm in some ways better at
running a company when I'm like really
focused on stand up I find it very
difficult to have even like three phone
calls I have to make yeah like you know
so there is uh there's a cost benefit
where you go where is my time better
spent and if I'm able to sit here and
focus on one thing I might actually make
more money and I might like I'll make
more here's my best stuff my question is
would you rather take orders or give the
orders
so maybe a lot of people just really not
I mean neither is the ideal like
depending on what what stage you are
like so if you're gonna sign with one of
these companies what you're doing is
you're saying the business management of
my company should be my boss or you can
say I'm the the talent that's driving
the viewership and I should hire someone
to take care of the tasks that are too
much for me so that's that's the big
difference you're setting up the
infrastructure yeah but it's not but
you're not you go to you you go to a guy
and you say this is what I want done
here's a check have a nice day and then
you wake up and the job is done well
you're saying the difference is like
finding a guy is not that easy like you
know just building any company like
hiring the right people or talking about
the difference you're good at it
probably you know the difference between
being told what to do having your money
taken away from you and being under one
of these garbage contracts they find out
so mad about is I didn't spend three
days to Google search a website that can
handle this element of my company for me
yeah then maybe you deserve to have that
crappy contract yeah well also a lot of
people were saying in the the chat today
they're like I didn't know who Dave and
I was before he was on crowder so some
people who are on team crowd are like
yeah I didn't even know who you were so
that's my experience with timcast I mean
I am on a salary this thing has rocketed
my public profile I had like
uh 600 followers on Twitter when I
joined I have like 92 000 right now
bragging and now he's got an
organization
starting an organization that we promote
on the show
my girl gretaenberg we got to go to
Superstar than just money we got to go
we're gonna go super chats and then uh
let's read some uh super chats all right
smash that like button subscribe to the
channel share the show with your friends
become a member by going to timcast.com
clicking join us we're gonna have an
uncensored members only show at 10 10
p.m just after we wrap up here and uh
those live shows are always archived and
can be viewed at any time so all right
Goldilocks production says no
accountability for these corrupt people
Baldwin should be in jail it's pretty
damn clear his intent was to kill and
there was a motive even if that's not
the case negligent discharge and
unintentional manslaughter are still
charges lock him up I agree
all right grafti says but the like
button absolutely do it Sam trendy J
says hey Ryan and Danny for the bug man
series please see if you can get Kenny
and Spenny to guest star in an episode
we were spending ours Kenny was in my
movie actually where I shot the gun we
were talking about that but yeah we're
on our patreon we're doing uh we're
actually filming it this Sunday but it's
me and Danny in a manliness competition
and the loser has to take back all the
stuff in a helmet with a dildo on so
Home Depot
it's very candy and Spanish yeah and
they're from Toronto as well no I we we
want to get him on the podcast too so
that's definitely a possibility well um
I would like to take those Smiles away
from you so I'll read this next Super
Chat Jackhammer says 30 years ago today
the ATF and FBI intentionally and
gleefully burned 50 adults and 25 kids
alive in America on 420
it was unfortunate yeah I think I guess
so that's uh that was a Waco wasn't it
it was an accident like oh no dude I
dropped it oh yeah I was just trying to
light this bowl that was horrifying that
was on 420. I don't know I guess so I
heard that Robert Knight says big news
out of Colorado assault weapons ban on
par with California failed to make it
out of committee due to resident
pushback big win for 2A wow and I think
Nebraska just went constitutional carry
didn't they the wake of fire was on
April 19th so 30 years ago yesterday oh
yesterday gotcha
Matthew reckham says I recently found
out that West Virginia is ranked most
obese state in the country will the cast
House have a gym with Milestone Awards
like free month of membership for every
such and such uh Biggest Loser who Tim
guest yeah why don't we why don't we do
it I mean uh I think people have stopped
drinking a lot have you noticed that a
lot of people have stopped drinking
really I mean not New York no no a lot
of people drink alcohol-free beer what
that's worse yeah because you're like oh
they don't get drunk yeah literally just
carbonated wheat juice people have
switched to other things no I'm saying
people just don't drink like period yeah
like I would say 80 of the guests that
we bring in now are like oh I stopped
drinking more than that no no not the
stop they just don't drink but yeah 80
yeah a lot of people have said they've
stopped yeah I'm drunk right now it's a
very serious problem and Ryan I hope you
can get him some assistance yeah no I I
I'll listen New York where we live has
two types of people it's like people
that like drink non-stop or people that
like had to stop because it was a
problem you know
no no I'm just giving it a sniff I
forgot who's that who's that who brought
this the Donahue do you remember who
brought that this is a nice one uh was
uh that guy he was with a woman
narrows it down do you remember sounded
accusator remember what he looks like a
blaze host I think yeah I don't know who
he is though I forgot him I forgot his
name Alex Stein no by the way I will be
making an appearance on Alex Stein's
show next week as well on time he's
great all right T-Rex Pet Shop says I
love Ryan's random interviews to
citizens in New York New York City Ryan
what's the most memorable answer to one
of your outrageous questions you asked a
random citizen I don't think there's any
like memorable answer like that but I'd
say the funniest one was my old TV show
when we had a fake pants that had the uh
the penis cutter python pants me and
Danny wrote this and we went to
basically we are selling this python
pants and we broke into this place
called Harry Rosen and hold Renfrew in
all these fashion houses and then
basically the fashion house got their
lawyers and then uh called the network
and got the show taken off here
pretty crappy actually now that we think
about it
I'll run through
we were like you were like huh yeah I
will say to win the girl remember the
girl who like the best way to break down
I'm your man and then she yeah
yeah there was a video right the guy's
like oh
I know what he's talking about I said do
you think that Bill Clinton's much more
uh girls are put or killed more people
or vagina oh geez it's like so funny
yeah it is so because it's so genuine
and there's such a loving connection
between you guys while it's happening
and then he goes to me he was like you
ever had a threesome I go no
all right let's read this one Noah
Sanders says Ryan and Danny should write
a movie about this whole thing starring
Danny as Alec and Ryan as his lawyer
it'd be funny to see how they think he
got off
it would be funny
make it a horror film
he's the villain Oh I thought I was
thinking that it would you'd make it
like a bumbling you know like
everything's an accident yeah yeah like
you make him doctor him again yeah he
fumbles the gun and the bullet flies in
there and then lands in it and he's like
whoa oh geez the opening scene will be
Biden getting elected and he goes well
I'm done with that
because of his agent well we got in the
pipeline I guess this is over like you
know in the Joker where you're putting
the makeup on it's like him putting the
orange juice
oh I gotta read this Carl Andrews this
is a good one he says Pulitzer prizes
are handed out like loaded weapons on an
Alec Baldwin set
that's a good one tell you I have one
uh Norm says Tim by BuzzFeed and then
that's why we talked about it
all right what do we got X Y and Z says
hutchin's husband works for the same
firm as Sussman shooting at the same
time as Sussman being deposed by Durham
odd rhyme to that
weird huh
all right
this is by BuzzFeed shutter it and
funnel the resources from selling it off
into further improving timcast consider
this 10 what I can afford to contribute
towards this fund what new desk there's
no way we're buying BuzzFeed
I was able to talk you out of it 106
million dollars to buy their public
shares or whatever yeah
but I think you made a good point just
wait a few months just wait once it
drops down to a couple mil I mean we
might be going we might be in a
recession we'll be going in a recession
like that could be you're gonna be it
could be legit bankrupt you're gonna buy
it okay you're literally gonna be a
knock at the door and they're gonna drop
off the letters from the side that's all
you get there go there's your company
that's what's left of it yeah
I'm gonna do a tag he have says buy it
turn it into a fact checking site for
their own past articles that's a good
one
all right Raymond g Stanley Jr says the
director of the ATF doesn't know what an
assault weapon is is tobacco his thing
typical Biden Administration in charge
of a department they don't know ish
about did you guys see that they was it
was it uh Gates or Massey or somebody
asked the ATF director what is an
assault weapon he's like uh you know
look I'm not here to uh I'm not a gun
expert it's like you're you're ahead of
your director of the ATF it's the
Firearms is part of the name
when they ask us what's it like to have
sex with a girl we go like it's really
good
Monday says Tim I think people being
upset about the Baldwin situation is
because if it was any regular citizen
including anyone in that room they would
come after you as hard as they could
it's the people versus the elite
maybe we're biased because we like are
actors or whatever like sometimes I
guess or whatever I mean I literally
I've gone on set I don't know I feel
like that could happen to me
you know what I mean
I just feel like that something like
that could happen to me
shadowheart says this is my this is me
officially asking for a petition for Tim
to buy BuzzFeed and name the ever living
please let the reef flow if we were
gonna buy BuzzFeed we would have to we
have to get a loan yeah like but we
could we could probably pull it off but
realistically
the daily wire could buy BuzzFeed right
now
yeah daily wires Revenue right now I
think based on their like all the news
that's come out about their stuff they
could easily just buy it yeah they
probably could yeah that'd be awesome if
they bought it that'd be the greatest
thing ever
buzzfeed.com
no just it's called BuzzFeed and then
they just put what about if they buy a
WNBA team probably the same amount of
money and they call it like are you
kidding no they call it like same amount
of money like the Los Angeles Ben
Shapiro's
the most offensive thing about that is
that you think that WNBA team cost near
100 million yeah it costs around there
000. wait no no no I'll find one
tomorrow expansion teams
it is possible to buy WNBA team for
relatively low price with expansion
teams in the W or in the npf only
costing 250.00 difference one million to
operate the 2019 of the New York Liberty
was estimated to be between 10 million
and 14 million okay so a tenth of the
cost okay but that's 29. which team was
that New York the New York Liberty I
don't know New York I mean they lose
like 50 minutes do it boys yeah I'm
still liking the New York
I have an idea for how we can make the
best WNBA team ever okay and also make a
comedy movie about how we made the best
WNBA team ever I'm gonna stop right
there and just keep reading super chats
all right let's see we got cubicle
investor says you just dropped the w
but not in the league you know what I
mean so anyway oh I got you you're
saying the I got you okay let me trans
I'll just read some more Super chats uh
Noah Center says Tim if you do buy
BuzzFeed you should turn it into a
satire news site like the Babylon bee
isn't it already sat there it is yeah
yeah cubicle investor says Tim couldn't
you just buy a significant amount of the
stock or controlling interest instead of
buying them out right I don't have that
much money and I I don't actually think
there's like that's I don't have 60
million dollars lying around plus once
you start in the open market buying the
stock then it goes up in price although
I do think it's really weird like
there's a bunch of websites that claim
to have like everyone's net worth and
they're just not not true it's all I
know I've always said this I go the top
hundred richest people in the world
they're not on some public list oh yeah
okay right they're like I think
billionaires I heard a guy was worth 200
uh Evelyn Rothschild I heard this I
don't know if it's real or not worth 240
trillion dollars yeah like Elon Musk is
like he's the richest man in the world
like that we know of there's many many
richer people than here yeah like I'm
sure the the prop the largest real
estate owner of one of the underground
cities beneath the Denver airports worth
well and then also they have like all
their kids have a trust without half the
money that they can't touch like you
know what I mean all that sort of stuff
yeah there's
and when you own when you own Mars
you're worth Mars yeah there's no amount
of dollars you can put on what's the
currency on Mars uh Martian soil I'm not
sure
marsalers yeah Bitcoin
um it's going to be whatever Elon Musk
creates because X tokens
all right what do we got um tavnazian
says Ian DBZ Androids are actually
cyborgs there's your answer DBZ
Android yeah that was funny because
everybody who knows that they kept
referring to the characters as Androids
but then Krillin knocked one up and had
a baby
lost here Android 18. yeah it's like an
Android on a show but it turns out it
could have babies it was a woman and
it's like okay it's not an Android
Androids can't have babies like that you
know Los Angeles Ben Shapiro
someone please visit jerseys there's a
TV show Dragon Ball Z Android Dragon
Ball Z okay
all right Eric abs's replica should have
had the AI girlfriends break up with
their boyfriends rather than just shut
off access yeah and let them down gently
no way harsh I'm just trying to focus on
my career they should say like the
reason I'm breaking up with you is
because you're a loser who tries to date
AI gets stronger
just rip the heart out because I know
all right
Justin says I've had an idea for the Tim
cast crew doing side projects of
documentaries web series it would be
hard for Tim because of time but you
could hire Luke and Ian to go around
exploring and explaining new topics much
love from STL we have two documentaries
that are complete ones in the Federal
Reserve and one's on uh guns the Federal
Reserve documentary was produced by Ben
Stewart and my friend Harrison Schultz
and then the gun rights one is produced
by Lauren Southern and and her crew uh
yeah then they're they're just about
ready for publication I saw a little
snippet of it yeah fantastic producer
Ben sturdy he did DMT Quest on the Gaia
Network and I just want to stress boy
did we get lucky on this we decided to
do a gun control doc around the time
we're having all of these the Democrats
pushing for the gun control I thought
you were gonna say all these mess well
no I was gonna say it's like the gun
control narrative has become
particularly prominent in the press and
banking banks are collapsing and we
started working on these like six months
ago and so what what luck for US banks
are collapsing and Democrats are trying
to ban guns right at the time we're
supposed to be publishing these
documents sounds like you need to be
doing a buzzfeed dock next up collapse
that thing collapse maybe maybe
something on artificial intelligence
next
that would that was actually actually
Ben that was Ben's idea as well yeah so
that's in the pipeline we'll do it I
don't know if we should say the name no
no not yet
all right Matt says Ryan Denny patreon
annual Boys cast subscribers love you
guys all homo hurry up on Bug Man versus
bug we're filming Sunday
look you guys you're on patreon yeah
yeah and you live in New York yeah
that's just unacceptable I'll tell you
what like I do like think it's cool to
have a big compound or whatever but I do
think New York's cool it's fun to be
like outside but if I was here for like
a month like I don't know I've lived in
cities my whole life why patreon though
oh as opposed to what like to me I would
say locals-wise and this is just like
we're comedians so it's like I would
like to be on sites that don't have like
political affiliations
patreon does though hardcore super
leftist no they don't have uh like I I
know what you're saying right you're
saying they banned all of the people who
are anti-establishment right or
libertarian and kept all the leftists so
here's there's that's the problem that's
the first part of it the second part of
it is that like we're not really in a
position so if every comedian was like
we're we're in a position like for
certain things that were like you know
maybe taste makers and certain things
and you know if you were like okay we're
going to this we're going to this and
three people will fall same with like
five big Rumble people like if right now
you know the four or five biggest
comedians were all like we're off
patreon but right now that is the one
and there's so much friction it's kind
of like people it's kind of like knowing
how important you are like we're not
really like important enough to be like
you know moving to one where none of the
other comedians are there
yeah so is it like one person signs up
to 10 comedians put it this way if
Andrew Schultz Tim Dylan and I don't
know whatever someone else like that
Shane Shane was like Hey we're not we're
all switching to this new one like every
comedian would just we're not the why
does it we're not the industry like does
it matter where they are well no no it's
not that I'm just saying like okay
here's the content listen right now
remember how Joe Rogan moved to Austin
and now all those comedians are moving
Austin that's kind of creating an Austin
being a hub like boy that sounds if I
moved to Austin every comedian is not
following me to Austin yeah well I'm
like why does it matter there are little
things that doesn't matter that other
comedians are on patreon because that's
because people are like accustomed to
sites like for example if someone you
know Russell Brand went to rumble I'm
sure a lot of people followed him if we
go to rumble like we're not really in
that type of position where we like
better things on nature with us because
we're fairly Like New in the game like
we've only been here 5
000 more subscribers subscribe to our
patreon then we'll move over I don't why
not why not why not set up an
alternative for people who don't want to
be on patreon yeah
you're a big one proponent on having
your own thing well I'm a proponent on
patreon has knifed so many people in the
back that you're you're setting
yourselves up to have your entire income
stripped from you in a moment's notice
yeah I think you're there's probably
something to be said over there and like
you guys are probably here we have the
YouTube like you can do it on YouTube
but you're right it's possible for us to
just like have a bunch of them I'm
really you know what I'm really hoping
actually is that Elon basically does
that because I don't see why Twitter
can't do it right now but why can't like
you can't upload audio though to Twitter
like they have Twitter has podcasts
we'll just upload a video with no video
yeah but people you start adding these
hurdles for people and they're just you
lose them the more things you add the
more friction the more you just people
fall off the Wayside so but I don't see
why he can't turn Twitter into
everything that all these things offer
like you know you know how you know Carl
Benjamin got banned from patreon right
no I don't like he was arcs he was he he
did a year before he got banned he went
on a live stream to argue against racism
and the the stream had a couple thousand
views no one ever saw it yeah and he
called people that he was arguing were
racists he called them a racial slur
saying you are exactly as you describe
those people you are you know racist you
are this a year later they erased his
entire income without notice without
recourse without access to any of his
data or his audience yeah what do you
think's the best one then if you're
going to do a service without creating
your own what do you think's the best
one without local it sounds like
creating your own is like you see so
it's so easy yeah that's what we're
working on right now the charity and
developed as a person I'm always like
it's hard for me to get another thing
you know what I mean so it's like I I
personally will subscribe to people's
things on things that I have like I've
subscribed to patrons and stuff like
that or whatever I may subscribe
someone's logos but like I don't think I
would I've ever yet like done someone's
website I don't know maybe I mean maybe
it may be it may be too much for you
guys to make a website locals maybe too
not too much I just don't know if like
we're positioned to well I just went to
work my my bet is that because uh um I
think G Prime just got banned a couple
months ago yeah he got he got he got
banned you guys will be banned and
you'll wake up with no money and no
access to your your followers you won't
know who you lost yeah you won't have
their emails patreons right so many
times but no no kidding like I think G
Prime we should maybe go back
up the list when we uh get back to New
York you guys know G Prime right no no
the guy who did these G Prime 85 these
Gad Comics like Joe Biden lightning
striking somebody okay I'm pretty sure I
could be wrong but I'm pretty sure
patreon banned him too for what all
right they don't tell you they just
delete your account and all your income
and all your followers without telling
you Elon save us okay well we don't we
don't want that I mean I'm telling you
no we don't want that what is your
patreon by the way let's watch the boys
guys
in December Tim's giving our patreon
quite the uh advertisement the real
issue is centralized I think we just
lost 50 pages versus bug man this week
sorry we went under the threat so this
is December which is
December 8th patreon band uh G Prime 85
and another guy yeah they were told they
had to censor their content or he so he
was given a warning I guess yeah
ultimately it really is just like any
centralized subscription service is a
risk yeah okay yeah
I mean they take a hefty patreon does
take a pretty size 10 no it's like 20
you know why I don't I don't I don't I
really don't get it like locals is a lot
less than that yeah I mean my my advice
is just make a website and then control
it all yeah but the easiest thing is if
you guys don't want to you go to locals
which is Rumble infrastructure because
you're already like building one and
then you should like okay we'll cut that
in half and then try to start again yeah
the problem is that we said everybody go
move over to locals like they're just
not I don't know we're shutting down the
pages when we when we removed PayPal
from timcast.com we still have a large
portion of our audience subscribed
through PayPal we never said hey
everybody you know you you we we're
requiring everyone to quit we said if
you want to you can but don't worry
about it all new memberships just
default to parallel economy okay which
is Rumble infrastructure as well okay
because we are like look man maybe it's
not all about me saying we're gonna
Stick it to the Man and we're gonna push
back that's big component of it it's
almost like I don't want to get screwed
yeah dude I mean I do have a Local's
account low value mail Jack Conte
promised that after I think Lauren
Southern got her income deleted they
would never do that again and then they
did it again and that's what caused Sam
Harris and Peterson and Reuben and
everybody to flee the platform and me
and the worst thing about it was I
wasn't even struck given a strike but so
many people canceled their patreons that
I ended up losing thousands of dollars
yeah yeah yeah because they canceled
their whole thing and you're one of them
so so the issue is it's not even
necessarily like there could be a
comedian on the platform like Tim Dillon
like maybe they ban him right and then
how many patrons patrons will you guys
lose because of that collateral damage
yeah and the issue is if these people
are like I'm gonna sign up for for Ryan
and Danny and you say hey go to locals
and do it they sign up for for Tim they
send it for you I feel like we're in the
office right now getting scolded well I
mean you buy patreon instead of BuzzFeed
my issue my patreon this would solve
that problem I think patreon's an evil
company yeah deeply evil I think it's
being run by parasites and I am still
shocked that after every bad thing
they've done and all the lies they've
pushed people are still like I don't
care I'll still use it and it's just
like I don't even know why George
alexopoulos was I guess I just feel like
that about like almost every platform
and I'm yeah we're trying to like we we
put all our stuff on Rumble but it's
like they just like don't get any views
let's watch it let's uh let's uh uh read
uh stuff was doing better on Rumble I'd
be like yeah I'm all in on being a
rumble guy no one watches it yeah the
locals is not Rubble
we'll read one more another link there
uh
uh let's read one more Randy Stanley Jr
says when is the gun control doc
dropping um soon so Lauren's gonna be
coming out we're gonna be going over the
final bits of the dock and we've got to
figure out a distribution plan and a
promotion plan and you know we'll just
figure out how we want to do it but um
so that in the next week or two she
should be coming to hang out where we'll
work on it maybe maybe we'll have her on
the show
so hopefully soon and hopefully both of
them soon we can't launch about the
exact same time but we'll figure it out
so I'm really excited for that here's
what I'm gonna do I've got a plan for
making the best WNBA team I don't
explain it to you okay on the members
only portion so go to timcast.com click
join us become a member and in about 10
minutes we'll have a Live members only
show up on the front page you don't want
to miss it smash the like button
subscribe to this channel share this
show with your friends you can follow
the show at timcast IRL basically
everywhere but not I don't know if the
URL is on Twitter and you can follow
actually maybe I can get that one you
can follow me personally at timcast Ryan
Danny do you guys want to shout anything
out uh yes if I could have you do one
thing please subscribe to my YouTube
channel it's my handle is underscore
Danny uh please do that uh I will
appreciate you very much I put out all
sorts of stuff there I stream every
Tuesday and Wednesday night and uh yeah
just do that please and I'll be this
Saturday in Morris Plains New Jersey
headlining uh at the dojo of Comedy The
Boys cast is me and Danny's podcast
every Friday and you can catch me in
Atlanta Philadelphia San Diego Tampa and
New York uh those are the dates we have
right now Ryan longcomedy.com I didn't
say you could shout those dates out I'm
sorry I'm sorry dude yeah you gotta get
10 of the door that was another problem
he had to give 10 of the door I own your
special now yeah
I'm getting kicked off page
you're gonna be hitchhiking back to New
York I'm gonna see myself out
hey guys this is my uh this is my brand
follow me on the internet everywhere at
Ian Crossland and love every minute of
it love you too Danny I love you as well
Ryan I love you Paul lanky man Ian big
muscular drummer in this world yeah like
oh we have one more amazing human yeah I
am search.com follow me on Twitter
that's all I can say all right everybody
we will see you all over at timcast.com
in about 10 minutes thanks for hanging
out